velopment committee and uh we we are
here to have a hearing on Senate Bill
146 uh I'll have U I have to read the uh
chairman script as everybody can hear
me okay I think it's okay all right as
chair of the house resources Recreation
and development committee I find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the
covid-19 pandemic and in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on a Senate Bill referred to this
committee with the potential for
executive session to follow please note
that there is no physical IAL location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meet the notice for this meeting
notice complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem access
accessing the meeting shall call
271 3600 or email
HCS
l.st
do.us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us Brad greenlands committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to no law uh before we take
attendance I like to to make an
announcement uh we have uh a a uh
attending this first part of this
meeting we have members of the uh
environment and agriculture committee
who will listen to the testimony and who
will ask questions during the testimony
and uh they they will help us on
resources and they will give us they
will guide us and give us
recommendations concerning a part two of
this bill uh with that I would ask the
clerk to call the role of attendance for
guny
RS
representa I believe that was Horan I am
home alone
thank you uh
representative here
representative I am here I'm in my
Al is here in the committee room
representative
DOD the clerk is
here representative
hey he's at
home and
post sorry I was having trouble on
muting um yes I am in my home and my
husband is in the
house representative Smith
representative Smith here and home and
alone
Spain representative Spang here alone
and my office at home representative
grassy representative grassy is here and
my wife is in the house as well
representative
botling representative
Cohen
I am here and
alone representative Connor
representative Connors is here and I'm
in my office
alone representative
Bale I'm here and my housemates in the
other room and there are two cats
representative Kelly representative
Kelly is here and
Grant
and chair I am here and surrounded
here okay and what
is 14
14 thank you very much all right now I'm
going
to walk forward launch into the uh uh
into the committee into the Committee
hearing a little bit of the this is a
unique
situation we have an Omnibus Bill which
has uh is six or which has six parts we
need part of the uh Bill
are uh as the expert the majority of the
is of the bill is the EXP is our re
resources uh part of resources expertise
however there are other segments of the
bill that are the expertise of other
committees uh we are we have here uh one
part of the bill part two which will
which will be helped which we will have
get guidance from uh by uh uh
environment and the environment and
agriculture committee uh and on this
afternoon at 1:00 we will be hear we
will be hearing part three and part five
of the bill uh with the aid of fish and
game department Fish and Game
committee uh and we will have the way we
will go about it we will have part part
two will we will be discussing
immediately follow after I finish my
Spiel
um then we will launch into uh into the
parts that are
specifically uh part of the
uh that the purview of resource
Recreation development committee which I
think is part one part four and part six
and uh at one o'clock as I had said
three and five will'll be we will
discuss part uh three and five with the
with fishing game uh a little bit of how
we will take some of the testimony uh if
if
any uh if any senators are available I
will or anyone who is uh who is a
sponsor of Senate
Bill
uh 140 Senate Bill
146 uh I will or take their testimony
first at any time that they wish to give
it
um and because I realize that know
senators and representatives have a time
constraint uh be beyond
that well we will we will start
with Section with part two then we will
go into see here part one four and six
All In all all at one time and then in
one o'clock we will go with the three
and five so if you're if you're uh if
you're want to testify on three and
five uh I would ask that
you it would be best that you return to
you to try to return to the hearing
after one o' uh with that uh we'll wck
the chair will recognize Senator
Waters thank you Mr chairman and uh good
morning members of the of the Committees
I'm Senator David Waters uh District 4
and I'm here to introduce Senate Bill
146 uh this Omnibus legislation comes to
you from Senate energy and natural
resources uh with a 5 to zero vote and a
23 to1 on a senate 4 and uh I do want to
start by thanking uh chairman Reno and
uh Pearl and Lang for all their great
work to make um this hearing work the
way it's it's going to work and I
certainly appreciate the difficulties
the Senate uh created by putting these
bills together you might consider it a
you know perhaps a tasting menu or sushi
um or uh you might consider it compost
or uh depending on what what committee
you're on but uh but here it is and
again I appreciate the um work from the
house chairs and others to see if we
can't get through this um I am starting
with part two and uh just a little bit
of um background on this uh we actually
passed this last year in the Senate and
it got tied up in in in uh in covid um
it is meant to renew our Solid Waste
reduction uh goal planning um this is
something that began in 1996 but was
then in ab bance and and uh it's been
really important to get this uh back in
place to do um Solid Waste Disposal
reduction um planning for the for the
state um this bill like House Bill 413
arose from the solid waste and recycling
uh committee chaired by representative
eel a couple of years ago a lot of great
ideas bipartisan unanimous came out of
that and uh so we have these um these
two two bills and um they're meant to to
work in Tandem and um to that end uh
after conversation and recommendation by
chairman
Rulo and um Pearl it seemed to make
sense that the Senate would amend House
Bill 413 which we had an energy natural
resource to add this bill um this
section to that which we have done uh
yesterday in um Senate energy and
natural resources thinking that that
might uh ease the process uh for for the
house um so let me um describe the bill
um for for you uh the real impetus here
is the need to reduce our Solid Waste in
any way we can because of our landfills
starting to fill up and also you know if
you talk to your municipalities you know
that you've seen a doubling and
sometimes tripling of tipping fees and
it's just really hammering local
taxpayers municipalities and so if we
can find ways to increase Recycling and
find markets for that and if we can find
ways to reduce Solid Waste we're going
to save taxpayers a lot of money and
also extend the life of our Our Land um
landfills um the bill was created uh
with with Dees of course um but also
working very closely with the waste
management companies you know cassella
um waste management and others uh to
make sure that we had a bill that
everybody thought um could work so just
to briefly look at the bill you'll see
that what it does is it sets some some
goals
for reduction of 25% by 2030 and 45% by
the year uh
2050 and some very careful definitions
of what gets counted in that goal that
uh the you know the Practical folks are
our managers and the municipalities and
uh the folks at the landfill said this
this is the kind of way to do that that
uh that makes um makes sense and these
um go goals are are similar to goals in
other other states and they're ones that
the dees really felt this is doable that
we we can get there on uh on these goals
over over 10 years um then um going
downward down a little bit uh it says
that we'll get an update every couple
years um from Dees on how uh this is
this is going and then um some
discussion of you know how this is going
to go forward with goals and strategies
opportun ities um on reduction on
Recycling and here's where House Bill
4113 is going to play such a crucial
role because that committee uh has been
set up in order to kind of do a lot of
the background work that can then feed
into this plan and uh that that bill
House Bill 413 carefully crafted the
house passed it uh I guess on consent a
few weeks ago and um it's a it's a great
Bill and so what that'll do is is uh
over the the next several months uh get
a lot of the information together that
then Dees and others can use in creating
uh creating the
plan um so that that's uh that's a
sketch of it and I'd be very happy to
have thank you I'm gon to recognize uh
chairman Howard pearl of the of v and uh
you also have uh sitting sitting is
identify your representative Bixby and
representative
Moran thank you chairman we have five
members of the ENA committee that are on
the hearing right now myself
representative vixman representative
Murray
representative and
representative so thank you Senator I
appreciate
your just want you to talk a little bit
further about the change that we made
over on the Senate side to the amendment
where we remove the landfill and
36 chairman I'm sorry to interrupt but
I'm getting a lot of feedback from the M
the two microphones talking to each
other if we can um either mute mute the
committee mic or mute representative PE
speak no it's
off how is it
now is that clear great y it's perfect
on my end there we go all right you need
me to repeat the question Senator or did
you hear I I heard it yeah um and and
thank you uh thank you Mr Mr chairman I
meant to mention that um in the
consultation about uh putting this um
part of the bill on to 413 the
recommendation from environment and
agriculture uh was that we make a slight
change on line 36 um the intent of this
Bill had always been to look at that
that 25 and um 45% as aggregate goals um
and we thought it was important to take
out the language which seemed to imply
that in landfills and and incinerators
each had to meet that goal and so th
that those that little phrase um was
removed so it's just the overall amount
of waste dispose and we're going to
trust our managers and uh the solid
waste companies and incinerator
operators to figure out just you know
how how they all participate in
achieving the goals so it's important
that this not does not set separate hard
and fast goals for solid waste disposal
and for incineration it's the overall
goal here that counts and thank you Mr
chairman for your question thank thank
you Senator I appreciate that uh I'll
turn it over to any other members of the
ENA committee if there's any further
questions that they would like to ask I
think the senator has done a pretty good
highlights Kelly has got a
question first first we just the
representatives of the ENA committee you
have any any
questions
Sen I don't see any hands from my
committee
members I'll I'll open open up
to
representa representative
Kelly I just had my hand up about the
microphone issue so I don't have a
question
okay microphone okay now this yeah it's
working great yep I hear perfectly thank
you uh yes representative M Mr chairman
thank you Senator thank you for your
introduction and and uh the goals of
this bill are are right on target my my
question though is as a citizen what
does this mean to make because it's the
citizens and businesses that create the
Refuge so how does this bill what are
the teeth in this bill that say okay
we're not going to create as
much well thanks for the question and
and really your question gets to the
heart of it as as I said that you know
we're really facing a problem with
solving Solid Waste capacity in the
state and um we felt that this bill if
we didn't do anything that the costs for
citizens are going to go up and up and
up I mean I I got to tell you in Dover
that we have the pay as you throw bags
and the price has gone up from like a190
to 425 a bag and um it's it's just it's
really getting to be crushing on
Municipal um budgets is seven several
million more in some of my my uh
communities over in District 4 so um the
way to help out local taxpayers is to
provide programs um to to help provide
markets and uh programs to make
recycling easier that all help that
ought to help businesses a lot with
their tipping fees as well and um then
you know through composting which is a
big interest of um uh of uh
representative eel and and others coming
out of that Solid Waste uh uh committee
um and diversion uh there are some good
ways to do that as well so um the point
is that you know the industry and you
know the the New England recycling um
Group which you know has all kinds of
Grants and programs to help
municipalities out in these areas
they're ready to go there's a lot of new
technology a lot of a lot of activities
um it looks like we're getting the
markets back in some of the recycling
with the opening up of the uh pulp
recycling plan up in up in Maine and a
lot of promising things developing on
Plastics as well so um I think we're
going to get there and uh to me it's
just it's saving the taxpayer dollars
that's that's that's bottom line for
me for a follow Mr for a followup thank
you just to to just to confirm what you
just said to make sure I understand that
this is focused on the industry figuring
out ways what to do with the waste
rather than the citizens and businesses
less
waste well thanks for that I mean I
think it's a flow um you know if we
encourage local composting um if we find
good markets for um recycling it means
you know municipalities rather than
sending materials off to the landfill
and paying for tipping costs can have a
market in the municipality um you know
they might get a grant to get them get
get a bailer so they can bail their uh
materials and um and sell them and that
that's another that's a good way of
reducing reducing costs I think also too
you know there's just lots of
educational programs that um can be done
to encourage people to to think about um
ways of reducing uh packaging or you
know think about ways of uh of um you
know using refillable thises and that I
mean it's it's consumer Choice um but to
me if you if in a way it gets
incentivized that you see that you're
going to save yourself and maybe your
community some money it uh you know kind
this represent Smith uh representative
Smith for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you senator for taking my question uh my
question is uh concerning page four
lines five six and seven um and when
we're discussing Solid
Waste we're to excluding automobile scra
auto motor vehicle waste infectious
waste asbest contaminated soil and I
just you know I know some of these
things
are uh recyclable or reusable and others
are just playing bad uh you know
hazardous uh things and I just wondered
what was the reasoning for excluding all
of those oh thanks so much for that
question I mean this is really important
for the industry and it kind of
recognizes the way materials are handled
um a lot of these materials are are
governed like ASB bestus of course um
contaminated Sals are governed by um
various you know statutes and uh Federal
Regulation and so on and there are
programs set up for
them and um it's not as if you can kind
of necessarily reduce reduce those uh
they have to get handled and so since
there's a kind of a an amount there that
you know you have to deal with and there
special programs for them it it seemed
um honorous then to include that because
if you're you're not going to be able to
reduce th that amount um then it means
like you've got to double down on
reducing everything else so this kind of
recognizes the way these materials are
are handled and um because they can't
realistically be included in a goal for
reduction because they're handled
differently um they're excluded from the
goal here I hope that makes
sense a little bit thank
you and let me say and thanks for your
question but I think if we have um Mike
whims or others from Dees here they can
tell you a little bit more about how
these programs are set up for those
materials
thanks any anyone else uh from the from
from the committee No
Hands okay uh just a a question on
procedure uh Senator Waters uh are do
you want to to speak on every
uh portion of the uh of the B of the
bill now or you going to uh follow along
with the committee uh as we go into the
other other parts later on in the day
well Mr chairman I I'm really at your at
your call and it seems to me it might be
um more useful if I just kind of waited
my turn on the other parts and um maybe
that if that works better for you I'm
happy to be
available well thank thank you I think
I'll I know I have uh is Senator Sherman
on the
uh on the list I know he's on the list
here um not certain don't see Senator
okay is there anyone uh is there
any any other Senator or representative
who is uh a sponsor
of this uh of uh the parts any of the
parts of Senate Bill
you if you know who up see no sorry
seeing no hands up then I guess we'll go
into uh the general
testimony
unfortunately
um Karen Karen eil yep I think we'll go
with that yep all right uh
up hello they had toote me to panelists
um good morning to the committee and the
uh members of Ena who are joining you um
for the record my name is representative
Karen eel and I'm here to testify in
support of part two of s SP 146 I
represent marac District 5 which is um
New London and Newbury um I listened to
the testimony presented by Senator
Waters and he covered a great deal of um
information about this part
um
the I was the uh chair of the recycling
committee which um I introduced a um a
bill a couple of years ago when I heard
quite a bit of information about China
not taking a lot of our refu and we
created a recycling study committee and
I would say that it was it it turned
into quite um an adventure
we uh we had um over 50 people
testifying in our committee on a wide
variety of topics we tried to bring in
all the stakeholders we could think of
uh businesses municipalities
recyclers um we had 14 hearings and it
was eight weeks and we generated um a
comprehensive report which was on a
great deal more than recycling it was
also uh generally on the situation with
Solid Waste Management in the state of
New Hampshire which we've been managing
all right but honestly you know when you
start to have problems that's when the
cracks start to show and we saw an awful
lot of uh cracks and some abysses out
there um so we made quite a few
recommendations in my testimony I gave
you the link to our
report um I also gave you some
information regarding landfill capacity
in the state of New Hampshire and um and
all of that sort of thing there were
several recommendations that were
particularly um important coming out of
this uh study committee which are
embodied in this bill and the bill that
Senator Waters referred to
hb413 which pass the house that creates
um a solid waste task force to work with
Dees um it also puts a deadline on the
production of the uh composting
regulations by Dees that we've been
waiting for for quite long time this
bill as Senator Waters uh
described uh basically
recasts the way that we're going to be
um seeking uh Solid Waste diversion in
the state of New Hampshire the last uh
time that we looked at this was in the
late 90s and the statutes currently
require us to achieve a
40% reduction in our Solid Waste by the
year 2000 so you can see that is really
really out of date um also the way that
uh it was set up in the statute for that
uh wayss to be tracked is not something
that really works for the department at
all so what we did um as you can see in
the
bill we um and I won't go through all
the details of it but we tried to make
it a two-step uh goal one for what our
goal was by 2030 and then another goal
for uh about 20 years later I remember
right I'm not looking at it it's 25 and
45% respectively and the
um uh also as Senator Waters said we
work closely with them on making sure
that we established uh uh methodology
for these goals to be achieved in a way
that reflects what's actually trackable
in the state of New Hampshire um I just
want to take an opportunity at this
point I know the members of the ENA
committee have heard this uh we really
have a problem in the state of New
Hampshire um the landfill capacity that
we have is is
dwindling um and I'm not here to uh
testify in favor of ever increasing
landfill capacity because in our
hierarchy of what we do with our Solid
Waste um landfilling is the last uh last
thing we should be doing we should be
trying to reduce our waste in different
ways um but our go-to me method has been
landfilling the decrease in the capacity
as increased tipping fees I know there
was a question earlier about the effects
on of of what we're trying to do here um
municipalities in particular are really
feeling the pinch because of increased
tipping fees
um and unfortunately uh the other part
of what we're talking about in this bill
is recasting our solid long range Solid
Waste plan program it had been set up um
for every six years we're going to
extend that to 10 years with this bill
to try to give more um really long range
planning opportunity than was provided
by the six-year uh program um it needs
to be said that we have not had a long
range Solid Waste plan in the state of
New Hampshire even though we're required
by Statute to have one every six years
since
2003 this puts us at a great
disadvantage because all around the
region other states are doing a lot of
planning on how to manage an issue that
affects every single person in the state
of New Hampshire and every entity these
regions among other things are doing um
Solid Waste bans which bans certain
items from being landfilled and when you
can't landfill it in your state and you
have a cheap way of getting rid of it in
another
state in some cases uh other states are
looking at New Hampshire um this doesn't
put us in a good uh place and we're not
able to ban out of state waste um under
the interstate commerce clause so we
really have to start developing
methodologies to uh
conserve um opportunities for the for
the people of our state um the other
thing and by and by doing more long
range planning I think we can spur
additional businesses using re reuse and
recycling uh we can do more composting
there's a lot of opportunities out there
that because we really haven't had any
kind of a plan since uh 2003 and a lot
of our permitting and other decisions
are based on a 2003 plan we need to get
with the pro program um this bill will
help a lot in that respect and I hope to
get your support and I'm happy to take
you all right are there any members of B
that have any questions for
representative
EV I do not
see all right is there any uh members of
uh resources that have questions of
Representative
eel you this is
represent representative eil does this
do these numbers of reduction um are
they based on a stable population growth
through year 2030 or what is that thank
you um I would I would defer to uh Dees
because we discussed this quite a bit
with them um I would say that it would
anticipate some increase in um in
population
um and also some business growth you
know uh you have to take a lot of things
into consideration when you take a t
take a goal like this and put it into
place and the other thing we looked at
in addition to popula we didn't specific
speically look at population we looked
methodologies thank you any other
questions for the representative by
members of RA
resources no questions seeing no
questions thank you very much for your
testimony uh I will now call
uh a member of the Department of
Environmental
Services
nor
okay good morning uh can you hear me uh
yes we can sorry about the delay it it
had me rejoin the meeting I guess um so
for the record my name is Michael norc I
am with the solid waste management
Bureau at
De um and uh wanted to provide some
testimony uh in support of part two of
Senate Bill 146 I think Senator Waters
did a great job setting it up and
representative eel also provided a lot
of great context so for the sake of time
uh I'll keep it pretty brief I also
provided uh WR testimony to members of
um resources Recreation and development
I don't think that we provided written
testimony to Anda but we can do that as
well just for context um but anyway I
just for for the sake of time I just
wanted to clarify
that one of the primary reasons that
Dees supports part two of this uh
Omnibus Bill is that it would
essentially reframe a goal that has been
as representative eel noted
uh many decades out of date uh it would
reframe it from something that is
difficult for us to measure to something
that would be much easier for us to
measure and if we're going to set a goal
it's very important to be able to
measure it so that we can track progress
towards achieving that goal one of the
problems that we've had with the current
goal is that it requires the department
to track data that we don't readily have
available um it wants um
basically it wants us to track
generation of waste throughout the state
and unfortunately that's not something
that we're set up to easily do um we
regulate Solid Waste facilities and so
therefore we can only track what's
reported to us from those Solid Waste
facilities and and unfortunately in the
world of solid waste not everything goes
through a solid waste facility so there
are some indeterminable amounts of waste
that are not sent to a solid waste
facility they might be generated
uh you know at a household and managed
at the household or you know things go
to donation or recycling that are
outside of the typical Solid Waste um
infrastructure so that's one of the
primary problems with the current goal
is that it requires us to measure
something that we don't re really have a
way of measuring very easily um
and what this what Senate Bill uh 146
part two would do it would essentially
reframe the goal from a diversion goal
to a disposal reduction goal and I know
that sounds kind of jargony but the the
whole idea is that it would allow us to
take data that we already have because
landfills and incinerators report to us
annually how much tonnage they are
processing um and so we can take that
data and it is definitive data and we
can track that over time to see if there
are changes and use that as a kind of an
indicator for um you know if changes in
disposal um happen over the course of
several years we can use that as an
indicator for um waste reduction or
recycling um and so those are ways for
us to at least have a definitive um
metric that we can use to track progress
towards achieving these
targets um and I think that that
basically uh is all I wanted to to say
right now but if there are any questions
from either committee
um happy to to take those questions
now thank you chair chairman
Howard jman
Pearl hi the works thank you are there
any questions from the members of the
ENA
committee I do not see any Mr
chair thank thank you all right uh
representative Kelly from resource es
you recognized for a question thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr nor for being
here today um just a quick question you
said that the uh tonnage numbers are
reported by the landfills annually are
is that just a one annual uh report or
do they report like monthly
numbers thank thank you representative
Kelly for the question
um the the data that we tend to use is
it's from an annual facility report so
it is something that's reported to us in
aggregate for the whole year um some of
the facilities do like like the
landfills for example will provide us
quarterly or in some cases monthly
reports of the tonnage um but they kind
of um use the annual facility report as
a way to kind of
um you know it's it's a way for them to
um reconcile the numbers for the year
some sometimes there are going to be
inconsistencies with those monthly
reports so we tend to follow what they
report annually just as a way
of as as more reliable
data okay thank
you any other questions from uh
resources so representative Smith had
her hand up and she load it
representative Smith you have you had
your hand up and lowered it is that your
yes okay thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr nor for taking my question um I'm
going to go back to the question I asked
of the crie sponsor about the exclusion
of automobile scrap absorbent media
contaminated soil uh industrial process
waste um he indicated that you could
explain better um because I was left
with a couple of questions still after
uh his so I just wondered um if you
could explain I understand that some are
already covered by Statute like asbestos
but if you could
explain uh why they are Exempted like
ash from wood stoves and uh
sludge thank you representative Smith I
I neglected to I do recall you asking
that earlier and I neglected to touch on
that in my testimony so thanks for
bringing it back up
um the the idea here I believe as I
recall
was uh some of the landfill operators
were concerned about um looking at Solid
Waste as a whole because there are
certain segments of solid waste that
there really aren't any good
alternatives for like you can't really
recycle um contaminated soil eat very
easily or asbest there's just nothing
you can really do with asbest except
dispose of it in a landfill um so they
were concern that if we were looking um
inclusively at all solid waste and
trying to and trying to reduce it by 25%
in the next 10 years or 45% in the next
20 years or 30 years
um that it would kind of put them at a
disadvantage because there are just some
things like what's excluded here in in
this section on on page four um that are
just it's there's nothing you can really
do with it except send it for disposal
so they wanted to kind of exclude that
from the the what the the goal was
trying to achieve because um so they're
trying to focus on the segments of the
solid waste stream that have reasonable
um opportunities for diversion or
recycling does that answer your question
does that make
sense uh yes but I do have a followup Mr
chair if that's okay for a followup yeah
so um in looking at sludge I know that
and also the ash I know like it locally
here we have a resource management and
their business is recycling or reusing
repurposing sludge and AD
to make a fertilizer and I just wondered
you know is there just not enough want
need for that kind of stuff so uh that's
a great question and one of the things
to clarify here is that it's um the the
use of the term Ash here is specifically
regarding U for example U you know Ash
from incineration of Municipal Solid
Waste okay what RMI manages is typically
um ash from wood like burning of biomass
or or other forms of wood and that is
not um there's a separate segment of our
our rules related to
um ash from from burning of wood and
that's something that can be land
applied for as you noted um you know
agronomic benefit um and with sludge yes
there are opportunities to use it for
land application
um I think think there are growing
concerns about management of sludge in
general just because of the issues
related to pest um so in some cases
sludge is being disposed in landfills
and that this is something that's been
going on for a long time even before PFS
that sludge has been being disposed in
in landfills I think there's also
economic concerns related to management
of sludge and some in some cases I think
disposal in a landfill is the most
economical for
so yeah sludge is a is a kind of a a
tricky issue because it's it's only
regulated as a solid waste if it's in a
landfill otherwise it's actually
regulated under RSA 485a which is a
whole separate statutory being water
program um and so I think the reason it
was included here is that if sludge ends
up in a
landfill um that it would be excluded
from the goal but there are
opportunities to use sludge and other in
other
ways okay thank
you yeah uh representative Kon thank you
Mr chairman uh Mr nor thank you for your
testimony
I why is it that you think that this
bill which sets goals which are which
are good goals to set requires you then
to track data and and receive data from
um the company
why is it that you think that this will
actually reduce the amount of trash what
what what is it about this bill that
that make that
happen thank you for the question
representative I
um this was a
a you know that this goal was first of
all the reason we we support this is
because this goal was out of date and we
needed to do something to update it so
that we have um no something to aim for
um I don't know that setting a goal in
statute um creates any mandate
necessarily in fact in the Senate um
Senator GAA requested that the language
be changed to State um it's on page
four lines nine and 10 that for the
purposes of of this section goal shall
not shall not establish a mandate so
there's nothing in this goal that would
actually um create a re requirement that
the waste be reduced across the board
however it
creates um it creates kind of a a
and again it creates kind of a goal or
something a Target to aim at and I think
um it also creates legislative
intent uh for additional waste reduction
and diversion initiatives um either
through
legislation um or it also creates an
intent for the Department to create
programs and planning that would help us
to achieve the goal um and and it's you
know something that is phased in um you
know there's there's two parts to this
there's the 10-year time frame where we
would hopefully be able to reduce
25% of the Total Disposal tonnage and
then by
2045 um or by 2050 rather reducing that
by 45% so it's trying to accommod
um you know a longer time frame so that
we can hopefully find ways to actually
achieve uh through you know actually
reducing the amount of generation the
total waste that we generate or finding
additional ways to recycle or divert
waste through composting or additional
um you know recycling programs like that
so to answer your question
representative I I don't think there's
anything here that would definitively
make us achieve the goal but it creates
the intent and I think that that's
that's the place to start appreciate
that thank
you any other
questions uh Mr uh representative Bixby
sir uh representative
Bixby yes um just to follow up on the uh
previous uh question uh so uh are there
ever grant
opportunities uh that uh Dees may have
access to that would uh be uh useful in
terms of getting funding to U meet these
goals and would having these goals as
part of Statute uh strengthen such an an
grant thank you representative Bixby
that's a great question um and that
really gets to the heart of the matter
of of how do we achieve these these
targets um one thing I just want to note
is that um many other states in the
region have robust Grant programs for um
incentivizing Reuse Recycling waste
reduction composting you know all all of
those those things that help to reduce
the amount of waste we're sending into
to disposal facilities that's not
something that we have the capacity for
in New Hampshire
um one of the reasons for that is that
the solid waste Bureau at Dees is 100%
General funded um and we used to have a
whole section devoted to technical
assistance and uh Community planning um
and that section was slowly through
budget cuts it was essentially disbanded
and it no longer exists and that's part
of the reason why the solid waste
management plan hasn't been updated
since 2003 that's part of the reason why
we don't have composting rules that are
up to date and that we've been
struggling to to get those uh rules
updated so there's a number of side
effects um one of and another side
effect is that we don't have available
funding to provide grants um whereas
Massachusetts the grants that they hand
out on a on an annual basis are well
over our entire operating budget for the
solid waste management Bureau here at
Dees um so you know it's it I think you
know creating goals is one thing but
actually being able to
incentivize um you know it's the carrot
and the stick kind of thing um you know
if you have the carrot to help get to
that goal um you know that really makes
the the policy much more effective and
unfortunately we just don't have that
right now Senator Waters in addition to
this bill last session did introduce uh
a bill that would establish a disposal
surcharge which would essentially go
into a dedicated fund and would be used
for um you know creating Grant programs
and technical assistance Outreach and
helping to fund D's work um and that
bill obviously along with everything
else during Co really kind of Hit the
hit the rail the third rail um so you
know there are there are ways that we
can maybe in the future get to that but
right now representative Bixby we are
not in a position to be able to do that
um the only program that we have right
now for Grants is a closed landfill
grant program which uh we help to reimb
reimburse municipalities for part of the
cost of closure of their old Town
landfill facilities um most of those
facilities have now been closed for 20
30 years and so that grant program is
kind of winding down um but that's the
only grant program we have there are
other Grant programs through
um third- Party U nonprofit
organizations like New Hampshire the
beautiful um they are an industry group
funded by uh the beverage industry and
and Grocers and
Distributors and they Target recycling
facilities so their their grant program
um is primarily for um you know helping
Municipal facilities to get a Bor or um
you know a new container for recyclables
or to so they're they're very focused on
recycling um but there are other
opportunities that maybe in the future
we could explore in terms of uh you know
developing infrastructure for composting
or helping to um you know get um you
know organizations off the ground that
do uh food rescue and help to keep food
uh you know from going into the into the
waist stream that can be you know used
to feed hungry people things of that
nature so that was a long-winded answer
I'm
sorry uh representative Bixby for a
followup yes um so thank you for taking
my followup uh I I think the the thrust
of my
my question I I I appreciate the
explanation of of um how
thees um can and can't use grants for
municipalities but what I was actually
aiming at was is if there's a
possibility for Grants from say the
federal government um I if the if the
infrastructure plan uh for instance uh
passes through the um Congress in
Washington uh then there might be an
opportunity for grant funding there
uh that Dees could apply for and then
use that funding to um to provide more
support for communities so I guess the
question really is uh would we be in a
stronger position applying for such
federal grants uh if uh we had in
goals that's a good question uh not
something I had that was on my radar I
haven't really been tracking the the
federal um you know the stuff going on
with infrastructure and other other
initiatives happening at the federal
level um but it's it's a good idea and I
think
um that it doesn't hurt to have you know
strong goals in our statute that would
help us to kind of you know support an
application like like the one you just
mentioned
any other questions no other hand ortion
no other hands Mr CH yeah representative
Pearl thank you Mr chair I'd like to
give a a shout out to representative
Murray she uh is on our Ena committee
and sat on this U Solid Waste working
commission as well so she's been a great
resource for us you're all getting to
hear some of the things that some of
it's information we've heard a lot of
times but U I think it uh it's very
interesting and I think your committee
has asked some really good questions and
I appreciate it well thank you very much
and thank you for uh for helping us
through this certain uh no other seen no
other questions uh
uh chair recognizes uh Reagan banet from
uh Northeast resources resource recovery
Association
don't uh there is I do I do have uh
Reagan on the
list you can raise your hand I do not
uh if not we not I there's no hand I'll
else Mr chair yes I have uh this is rep
Smith and I have another question from
Mr norc sorry I missed it the last time
around M Mr norc are you there still I'm
still I'm still here all right you may
ask your question representative Smith
thank you very much going back to my
initial uh question and I wondered what
is that is I believe referring to
um waste produced by an industrial
manufacturing process so the for example
like casting sand for some facility that
might be uh casting metal they might
have sand that is uh used in the casting
process that then needs to be disposed
of after it's been used um that's just
one example there are probably a
multitude of examples that are you know
possibly generated within the state um
but it would be different than waste
produced at the same facility but in
their cafeteria or their uh break rooms
or things like that which would be more
in line with Municipal Solid Waste kind
of you know just general
refuse does that help to to
clarify uh a little bit I mean I have no
idea what casting sand is but um it's a
start and it does help to separate it
from like the cafeteria waste you're not
saying any waste from a industrial
facility correct okay thank
you
go to someone else John
G
system
okay good morning to the committee and
me uh my name's John gay I'm an engineer
with cellaway
systems and um I would like to uh thank
the committee for uh its hard work and
also agree with Senator waters's earlier
statement that um we're going to get
there on this resource uh recovery and
reduction um it's going to take some
hard work uh but I think we're all
motivated to uh make sure that this is a
success and I think the education it was
also mentioned is going to be a big part
of uh those accomplishments um as well
uh so I'll be brief and and just want to
say that we absolutely support part two
of this bill and we fully offer our
experience and resources uh in the Wast
and Resource Management Field to help
New Hampshire determine how to not only
set up the appropriate goal but also to
get there and achieve it um our regional
vice
president uh has uh provided written
testimony uh that uh when you all get a
an opportunity to take a look at it um
there's more information in there that I
useful so we currently transport um more
than 30,000 tons of New Hampshire
recyclables out of state uh down to
Massachusetts and the cost of the
transportation has proven to be a burden
for some New Hampshire
municipalities and uh has resulted in in
for some cases the abandon ment of some
of the recycling
programs uh so we want to try to uh
reverse um some of that from occurring
one of the main keys to establishing and
achieving a waste reduction goal will be
developing the appropriate comprehensive
infrastructure uh in New Hampshire that
includes uh perhaps a new recycling
facility to my knowledge there's no
large scale recycling facility in the
state and um that is going to be
something that you know we want to try
to uh keep in Focus as we move forward
uh we commissioned uh consulting firm
DSM Environmental Services uh in Vermont
to take a look at um uh what it might
look like to have a a large scale
materials recovery
facility um in the state
and uh we do we do feel as though it
will be extremely beneficial and could
um
uh amount to an annual reduction of
greenhouse gas emissions by more than
29,000 metric tons of carbon due to
increased recycling rates and of course
decreased transportation of the
materials that's currently going to
Massachusetts now that's the equivalent
of removing more than 6,000 Passenger
cars uh from New Hampshire roads each
year uh so you know once again I want to
encourage you to read the materials that
Brian has offered in the written
testimony um and certainly support again
once again support the bill um we uh we
uh we have a comprehensive system in New
Hampshire and we would like to see that
system um become more robust and it's uh
it's encompassing everything that
that that happens uh in New Hampshire
from the hierarchy with
uh recycling uh all the way down to
disposal I know there's been a lot of
questions about disposal uh this morning
um we need to try to move away from that
and into um more reduction and and agree
with uh Senator Waters and uh the
committee and their
work happy to take any questions that
have thank you Mr is there any questions
G seeing any Mr CH we have a question
from
represent you
do
up thank you uh I just wanted to request
that uh um Mr Gay testimony be um be
shared with the environment and
agriculture committee that's
all all right can certainly do that
thank you representative we make sure
you get a copy of
that thank
you no other
questions no other questions thank you
very much for your
testimony uh Steve uh POI uh Waste
Management
Inc
up good morning can you hear me yep I
can hear you yes hi good morning
everyone um yeah well I'd like to uh
just give you a little bit of background
on uh us as a company um and our general
support for the bill my name is Steve py
I'm the area director of disposal
operations for Waste Management in New
England I'm a registered professional
engineer in New Hampshire and have over
35 years of experience in the saw Waste
Management Field in my current role with
Waste Management I'm responsible for
permitting compliance construction and
the overall operation of our transfer
and Disposal Network in New Hampshire we
have operations in London londonerry New
Hampton Keane Auburn lonia and
Rochester our Rochester operation
includes the turnkey recycling
environmental Enterprise facility which
Services about 40% of the solid waste
needs of the state and provides
Approximately
80% of the energy needs of the UNH Duram
campus through the ecoline Lano gas
pipeline which is a dedicated pipeline
providing LF gas to the University
campus we have a valuable perspective on
the realities of solid waste management
in complying with the laws and
regulations in New
Hampshire uh first off I'd like to
commend the work that's been done by the
Legislative uh Recycling and Solid Waste
Management study committee formed back
in
2019 and the work they've done to
address the various Solid Waste issues
faced at with folks in the state we
participated throughout the year-long
effort by the study committee assisted
with tours of the turnkey facility in
Rochester and our regional recycling
plan in
bka we're in support of a solid waste
reduction goals being discussed here
today and believe it will help simplify
the tracking and efforts to reduce the
amount of Municipal Solid Waste being
disposed the current law has created
challenges for Regulators in the
regulated Community during the more than
30 years it's been used to guide the
planning of Waste Management activities
in the state
should also be noted that the goals that
it set back in 1990 were never
met the legislation being proposed today
Target solid was streams that can be
recycled or reduced PRI to disposal it
also excludes those materials that are
not readily recycled such as residuals
coming from recycling
operations
asbest contaminated soils
sludges incinerator Ash Etc and it sets
a clear goal for reducing the total
amount of solid waste disposed in
landfills and
incinerators it'll also avoid confusion
in the current law as you heard Michael
knor from Dees speak to on how to
measure and track waste diversion and
instead sets an overall limit on the
disposal of Municipal Solid Waste in
construction and demolition debris we
believe the change is important and will
lead to reducing the amount of Municipal
solid wasting construction debrises
disposed in the state at this time i''d
be happy to answer any questions that
the committee may
have all right thank you Mr POI is there
D see none I don't see any question okay
resources I do have one question uh yes
Mr Po thank you for your testimony the
one thing you said that that struck me
is that the goals set in 1990 were never
achieved um do you know why they were
not achieved and why was this why will
this bill be different and why would we
achieve the goals with this
bill okay I I can address that thank you
for your question um the reason why the
goals in 1990 were not achieved is I
think uh and you heard the dees
representative speak to this it was a
difficulty in
tracking the numbers that go into the
calculation to determine what is
diversion and there's still ongoing
discussions and debate on those types of
materials that should be considered in
establishing a diversion rate in the
state of New Hampshire uh the state of
New Hampshire has certain criteria for
defining what solid waste is and the EPA
has a different definition so there's a
lot of conf confusion and disagreement
on that the new bill going forward sets
a pretty simplistic number they
basically have identified a target of
what was disposed in the incinerators
and the landfills in the state of New
Hampshire in
2018 and is basically
said in you know 2030 and 2050 that's
going to be reduced by 25% and
45% that will be very easy for the dees
thank you sir that's your
question any other
questions if not thank you very much for
your
testimony
you any is ready I do not
see okay uh one of the problems with uh
remote testimony and the system we have
it doesn't
allow for showing up whether well what
uh what parts of an Omnibus Bill someone
wishes to testify on it's I've been
lucky as I did do have the uh written
testimony of most of the people who have
uh spoken and uh and I just was a I was
able to track that but there are several
other some others who uh wish who say
they wish to speak but they may be on
other portions of the bill I presume uh
Ted deers is wish from Dees who wants to
speak on something other than than
two
[Music]
deers yes I apologize my uh Zoom just
collapsed right as you called my
name thank you
Mr you're kind of uh at least I you kind
of sound like you're talking in a far
away hold on one second let me try to
sir
how does that sound sounds great now
right how's it how's it sound how's it
sound to everybody else okay okay got a
a lot of got a lot of Thumbs Up all
right keep going we all know you okay
great thank you sir I appreciate it uh M
Mr chair members of the sub of the
Committees both committees if they're
still on um my name is Ted deers and I
am the ad administrator of the watershed
management Bureau at the Department of
Environmental Services and it is my
great pleasure to be before you today
with uh this part two of Senate Bill
146 um this bill uh came out uh you have
testimony I believe you all have
testimony from us it was sent out uh I
think yesterday or the day before um I
won't read the testimony I'll just note
a couple of items about sort of where
this came from and where this is headed
um the coastal program has been around
for quite a while uh I was the former uh
director of the coastal program uh and I
knew many of you from from that role the
the impetus for this particular Bill
really comes out of a couple things one
is the re is the relatively recent uh
changes to the SEC process the uh that
is the sighting evaluation committee uh
as we were looking through that it
became clear that the linkages uh
between how Federal consistency review
and I'll talk about that in one second
how Federal consistency review and the
way that uh the SEC uh law was set up we
needed to make some changes to our
program to accommodate those changes and
as we started going through that it
became clear and clearer that one of the
challenges that we face is making sure
that the actual program itself which is
which administers funds from the from
the uh National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration under the um uh authority
of the coastal zone management Act
that that had
a are you are you talking on speaking on
part one or part two sorry part one oh
okay yeah that's I figured uh yeah the
that's we're gonna be do doing that very
shortly okay yeah I
rewind uh yeah rewind yeah I I apologize
the reason I uh because it didn't
because I did see Mr nor uh and you both
from the dees I didn't know if you were
both testifying on part two want to just
let me just wrap up part two it should
take only a few seconds um this uh we do
have on the list uh Senator
Sherman uh is he's there at all uh I did
not see okay and uh I do not see anyone
else on the list who wishes to
speak uh no hands are raised and no
hands are raised okay uh unfortunately I
can't read who might be uh in favor or
against uh this bill and do not wish to
speak because of this the because of the
because of the issues with the system
itself the shortcomings of the of the
system to handle Omnibus bills that
being the case I think we have had all
the testimony on part part one uh
I uh I think we can close the testimony
on part one I thank the
representatives from
Ena chairman Pearl and uh his his
committee and I hopefully you'll be able
you I'm certain you'll get back to us
with uh some
recommendations and I appreciate you
you're helping us well thank you
chairman renz we we appreciate the
opportunity to participate in this bill
with you and uh we'll certainly offer
some some guidance as we see it from me
Anda thank you I want to
thank question I'm sorry representative
hand you
already chairman PE continue well thank
you I was pretty much done anyway but we
we'll certainly provide some information
for you and I want to thank the members
of Ena who came in today and
participated so thank you
all thank you let me uh representative
harb do you have a
question yes I had a question Mr
chairman I I thought I heard you say
you're closing testimony on part one but
I thought we no excuse me part part two
no we'll we'll be opening testimony on
part one uh I'll I'll I'll speak how
we're gonna we're going to do all of the
testimony
on uh
on part uh on the resources section of
the
uh of this bill uh for the rest of the
morning uh but let let me finish off
here uh thank you thank you very much
and give us let's give us about a five
minute break we can uh and then we'll
minutes
[Music]
folks all right okay I think very all
right we're we're now going to try to do
the bills that
are strictly the purview of the uh
resource Recreation development
committee and that is part part one
which is the establishing a coastal
program administered by the Department
of Environmental
Services
um part four which is tital
Waters and part six which is public use
of
coastal uh
shorelands uh obviously I think the big
hitter in there is going to be part one
the establishing of the coastal program
administered by the Department of
Environmental
Services and with that I will recog
nice Senator Waters again sorry to keep
you waiting sir oh this is great and
thanks thanks so much Mr chair members
of the commedia and again I appreciate
so much you're finding a way to make
this all work um well Ted deer started
to kick it off but uh part one here um
this is another one that we passed last
year in the Senate and then it got cized
and here we are uh but this um puts into
State Statute the coastal programs now
the coastal program already uh exists it
was a established by federal statute in
the coastal zone management act and it
is a vehicle uh to receive funding from
Noah and then to really help out our
municipalities and our agencies when
they're planning for um resources
Recreation and to me most importantly
Economic Development to on our on our
Coastal uh areas and um we need to play
place this in state statute for a couple
reasons which I'm sure Ted deers will um
go go into too if it's in State Statute
it not only helps us with Federal
consistency meaning that we can take
whatever Federal Regulations about
coastal zone or coming coming through
and help our uh municipalities uh deal
with them um but also it means in if
it's in State Statute that the program
can much better serve state agencies and
our local municipalities uh in these
these ways I'll get into the details of
the program in a in just a moment but I
want to also act another important thing
that this um section does is that it
establishes a um a a fund uh that can
then receive those Grant funds and
perhaps other funding as well that might
become available and make sure that that
those funds are spent the right way and
spent the way that um you know that we
have some ways to supervise that in the
in the legislature there's Ru making
around that as well and I think that's
good for transparency but I also think
it really will help um provide an
opportunity for us to get more funding
from the federal government and other
sources here and to that point um
there's no FN attached here we're not
talking about um expenditure of
additional State funds with this it's
just getting the program and statute and
also I I I think I want to note because
it came up a lot in the Senate hearings
um that this program in and of itself
has no regulatory Authority it it's
really meant to help municipalities and
agencies deal with regulations that that
are coming down in the coastal zone um f
from federal um acts and other other
ways as well so um just to look briefly
at at it it uh more or less the language
here describes what the program um is
doing um we have just incredible
environment along our our Coast great
natural resources which um are important
to preserve for the health of the
waterways but also for the health of the
people I work doing on Great Bay and on
on the coast um and then it's these
resources are important uh not just
because of you know the beauty of them
but also because this is what Recreation
is all about on our Coastal area and
also what great assets for economic
development as
well um so you can see here under the
establishment of the program um it
purpose is to do uh just that and you
have those listed in numbers uh one one
and two on page uh two and um the uh
particular aspects of the the um you
know flood prone zones the coastal zones
storm surge and all and this becomes
awfully important in the ways in which
the coastal program helps welome
municipalities I mean for example if
they want to plan for um a waste waste
management water a water plant um just
how are they going to build that and
make sure that it's going to be able to
operate
um safely and be protected and resilient
uh on the coastal um Coastal conditions
also um lots of good programs uh too
they they provide grants and other
programs to help municipalities deal
with Coastal erosion Shoreland shoreline
erosion and those things as as as well
um and then uh if you go a little bit
further down um the management here uh
and what it's supposed to do starting on
line 18
um you know here's you know clearly the
the heart of it for me is the
recreational opportunities and economic
um development uh to make sure our
communities can continue um to to
thrive another function here too is the
comprehensive planning function um you
know we have a lot of of planning that
has to be done um along our coastal zone
and uh we have some acts that govern
that and of course the Rockingham
Commission straford uh County Commission
also helps out with planning as well but
a lot of municipalities really need need
help in their their planning uh looking
not just for you know Wastewater or
other kinds of economic development but
also for coming Coastal conditions in
terms of storm surge and flooding and
other things as well so this this
program really steps in and helps out
with the planning um for municip
municipalities and then finally just on
page three uh there's the fund that I
mentioned um establishes a a fund
dedicated to this and um the monies that
can come in and then the rules to make
sure that the money is distributed in a
transparent and uh in ways that um
fulfill the uh purpose of the of the
funds and give give the state uh
appropriate oversight of that as well so
uh Mr chairman um there it is and uh you
know Ted deers is here but I'm happy to
take any
questions any questions for from members
I did have one question representative
kraton Senator again thank you so much
in the goals established um on first on
the second page are excellent goals um
but I'm confused on where the money
comes from if you establish a fund but
that doesn't come out of state funds
where does that money come from well
thanks for your question and um you know
Ted can give more detail on that but the
major funding for the coastal program
and the coastal management act comes
from Noah and they they provide grants
to the states that have the coastal
programs and that's that's that's the
major source of funding here um so when
those funds come in now we'll have a
place to this dedicated place to put
them and also has the transparency and
uh rules around it that you know I think
are really we always want in the
legislature to see
that okay thank you
sir any other questions for the senator
there no other hands
raised there all right seeing no other
hand raised thank you very much Senator
deers thank you very much uh can you uh
hear me okay uh yep here you're fine
thank you Mr chair I uh apologize for uh
jumping in ahead of the uhe of the the
gun there um so uh uh I you know know I
was very just very excited to to enter
into this conversation
um I'm not going to repeat uh much of
what I said except that uh just to note
a couple of things um this idea uh of
funding that uh not only does the the
coastal program received kind of an
annual allocation from Noah but the
program has been extraordinarily
successful over the years at bringing in
other grants and that's one of the
important pieces here almost every
dollar
uh that comes in outside of the the just
the the the basic amount to support
staff and offices and all that kind of
stuff is passed through to the
municipalities I think this was
mentioned by the senator um over the
past years we have literally passed
through millions of dollars to the
municipalities for long range planning
for projects for restoration projects um
and so that that has been very helpful
to the communities and to the ecosystem
salt marsh restoration you know lots of
those kinds of things which have
happened over the years um I would also
note that if you've seen some of the
what's coming out of the current
Administration and even the last
Administration um there's a real focus
on Coastal hazards and you know I think
that the PE people along the coast
understand that they're seeing more
stronger storms they're seeing more uh
what we call you know uh Sunshine
flooding uh which is what happens to in
extremely high tides and those tides are
getting higher over over time and so
this idea of of really trying to bring
in resources to help the communities
with those is important in fact uh if
you saw the article yesterday from um
maybe it was in today in the paper
relative to some of the uh the meetings
that were happening with the new uh
Secretary of Commerce um out in the Sea
Coast uh former Senator Styles uh Nancy
Styles who's been a strong advocate for
our Co Coastal communities for many many
decades um you know she was talking
about this need for additional funding
to support the long-term planning and
and really trying to figure out what
we're going to do to make sure that
those uh communities and economies along
Route 1A uh are going to be supported
over the long term and so that's I think
really important the other piece that
I'll I'll mention and I can't believe
Senator uh Waters didn't talk about this
was the ongoing discussions of offshore
wind energy um
he chairs a committee in fact we had a
meeting yesterday and one of the
important things that just came out
yesterday in the meeting was the
concerns of our fishermen uh about the
placement of a future placement if we
ever do get it of offshore wind uh that
would bring electricity into our our
grid here in in the
Northeast one of the things that Federal
consistency does and this is it's a very
Arcane little piece of of legislation um
is it requires any federal activity to
be consistent with state laws and that
is super important it's one of the few
places where the states have this kind
of uh Sovereign right to be able to
address what's going on and being
permitted by the fed by by the feds and
so this is really important you know
relative to some of those concerns by
the Fisheries to make sure that we have
tools back to our state laws and our
state policies the policies that you all
create to make sure that as that
important industry grows that we take
into account very strongly those
concerns of our fishermen so and and and
and other kinds of stakeholders as well
so I just want to note that there's some
really important aspects to this not
just for where we've been but I think
that where we're going as well and I
want to Echo Senator uh Waters uh
comments about that that the fact of
having this in statute is important uh
probably more more important now than
ever and to thank you and to thank the
senator very much for introducing this
piece of legislation and I'll stop there
and just see if people have questions
complicated any questions for Mr dear
sir I see no questions no questions at
the moment I I do have a question or two
uh Mr deers uh I'm kind of a you know I
need I view things in pictures I guess
and that's why I like kind of
flowcharts uh you have with this looks
like there's Federal money that's coming
in somewhere to the state and somehow
getting through to the towns yes uh
and what does it look like now as
opposed to what it will look like what
will the picture look like once this uh
uh Coastal program is established in
state statute
thank you for the question this is I
think probably one of the the
challenging Parts uh to understand the
fact of the matter is is that we do have
a mechanism uh currently to bring in the
general you know not the general funds
the federal funds that are generally uh
allocated to the state we have a
mechanism to bring those in as we do
other grants from EPA and other things
like that the the fund that we're really
looking at here is is a much more
flexible kind of fund that would allow
for other kinds of Grant
uh you know potentially from
foundations uh you know other kinds of
activities that could go on in which
this fund could serve as a a place to to
put some of this so for example if a
couple of communities wanted to join
together in a project that becomes very
challenging for two communities to
figure out how they deal with the
physical nature of of giving money to
each other um whereas having kind of a
having a fund like this and onlaps fund
would allow us to be able to have that
kind of mechanism to allow for
communities to enter into those kinds of
projects seek out grants uh whether it's
private or or government funding and be
able to implement the kinds of projects
that they'd like to do so that's I think
the kind of opportunity this that this
creates it's a more flexible uh approach
than we've we've had in the
past for a followup uh will the Noah
funding go into this fund or Noah money
go into this fund or will it be other
funding or both thank you for the
question I'm not entirely sure yet I
think this is one of the things that we
would have to right now because we
already have the Noah funding uh in the
proposed budget for the
2223 budget I think it would certainly
go there this would be an interesting
conversation to have when we start to
generate the uh 20 uh 24 five budget um
which scarily enough will happen in just
about a year uh so um anyway that that's
that's the discussion that we'll have
budget okay all right the any additional
any questions for anyone else from the
uh from the committee no further
questions no further
questions I thought there'd be a lot
more
questions uh
all right seeing no further questions is
uh
should that's it all right that I guess
that's it on part one of uh of the of
the of the bill
um next part of the uh bill is uh item
four on tital
Waters
Senator Waters to talk on title
Waters thank you Mr chairman that's
right I'm I'm up to my neck and Waters I
guess this today with you all um still
Senator David Waters District 4 I'm here
to introduced uh part four of Senate
Bill uh
146 um this uh Bill the simple seemingly
simple change here is somewhat technical
but awfully important for New Hampshire
as it gives us some standards uh in
state statute for uh determining um
levels of um these uh these chemicals
feto C form and others in our our Waters
a little bit of the background of this
um this came uh to me from the state
Association of Municipal Water
managers and um they need it for a
couple of reasons
uh one in the coastal area and
particularly the communities around
Great
Bay that there recently has been a
consent agreement signed with the EPA
about how to measure uh nitrogen in the
Great Bay Waters coming out of waste
water treatment plants and also from
other
sources that you know there are lawsuits
there were there just activity for many
many years to get to the place where um
the municipalities under this new
agreement are giving some Authority uh
to try to reduce the nitrogen from lots
of different sources not just the
wastewater treatment and why that's
important is we're about to get hammered
with another 100 million dollars that
we'd have to spend to upgrade water
treatment plants which had some of them
just been constructed or just been
upgraded at the cost of 20 to $30
million to meet certain standards so the
argument the communities made was look
give us more
flexibility and we will be able to get
this this done and one of the important
things here was to be able to have in
State Statute the measure we were going
to use for mollusks for
aquaculture um because that was one of
the standards of Cl of cleanliness that
was being used um at the national level
and uh we did not feel that the
standards from the national folks were
really appropriate for the our our
Waters and by having this then it gives
us um an opportunity to negotiate and to
say this is a better this is better
reflects the cleanness of the water uh
here and then secondly um a lot wider
range of communities are now being
affected by the ms4
regulations and uh here too uh having a
stat um standard and statute will help
us uh in in negotiating
um over what the implications of of ms4
are going to be for the communities that
are affected um by it so um with that
said and I think we'll have some other
testimony some of the technical uh
details here um but what it does is
updates the reference to the um Federal
uh program there and what's important is
that it breaks out here it says here's
the standard that we think is right for
the state and then the analytical
methods and sampling you yes we will
follow um uh those by developed here by
the Department of Environmental Services
that's really important um approved the
the kind of methods that are then
approved in the latest revision of the
national shellfish sanitation program so
what it really does it gives it gives
the state the power it needs and the
standards it needs to clean up the water
but not not be under the not be um you
know under the demands and perhaps
inappropriate standards sometimes of the
uh of the EPA on this so um that that's
it Mr chairman and um have you got to
take any questions and I I do think
you'll probably have some folks from the
uh Water Association who can talk to it
as well if not and Ted deer let me just
add to is that um this has been vetted
by the folks in Fisheries um by Sheree
Patterson in fishing game and by Steve
coocher in Dees and and uh they thought
this is Thoroughly appropriate for the
protections we want to have for our
agriculture um industry and Hampshire
and thank
you is there any uh questions for
members of the committee I see no
okay coming off mute okay all right M Mr
deers I do have something from Dees even
though it the the boss always signs his
name he does mention you so he's taking
my name in vain once again thank you uh
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I am still Ted deers uh from
the Department of Environmental Services
and um if you thought that the coastal
zone management Act was uh was Arcane uh
wait till you see this bill um this is
where the Clean Water Act intersects
with the national shellfish sanitation
program and uh that's where it gets fun
so um really quickly uh what this bill
and and Senator Waters did a fantastic
job of trying to lay this out for you um
essentially what this does is currently
it it's it solves a problem in in
sampling methods that we have currently
uh we have a method for for for sampling
Waters that everyone is using in the Sea
Coast um and it's a great method it is a
way that you can actually uh gather the
water and you incubate it right there in
at the wastewater treatment plant it's
so simple that even I could do it um so
it is it is really a slick method and
what the problem that we came across is
that a strict reading of the regulations
that we had and the strict read reading
of the regulations as EPA was reading
them would dictate that we could not use
that kind of methodology we had to use
an older more Antiquated technology that
required significant expense on account
of the wastewater treatment plants in
order to uh comply with it and not only
that it was a slower method to actually
yield results so so we had this
conundrum and so what we've done is this
this piece of legislation mimics the way
other states have avoided this issue um
it does link up both the Clean Water Act
regulations that EPA is looking at when
they're writing permits as well as the
shellfish sanitation program regulations
that we're looking at when we're making
sure that it's safe for you to go eat
those oysters and clams and muscles um
which are amongst my favorite of foods
um and so what it does is it allows for
that to happen it will once this goes
into place it will save the wastewater
treatment plants money and yield a
better ability for us to regulate the
shellfish program so that if there ever
is a problem we can immediately respond
and make sure that no consumers are
getting uh you know fouled uh shellfish
so it's it's a really important little
tiny piece of legislation that is
incredibly I know it's technically
challenging uh to look at and to
understand I hope that the letter that
we produced helps um and if you have any
questions at all I'm happy to answer
them and I believe that there may be
others uh from the industry who are also
available um to be able to answer their
questions from their perspective so with
that I will open it up to any questions
that the committee might
have questions from members of the
committee sir I see no question from
okay there's uh no me no no questions uh
there is no one
else signed up to speak and other than
uh uh Paul Sanderson from fish and game
and I believe he's speaking uh
uh on items three and I guess three and
five the part that fishing game will be
part of uh is there anyone from the
audience who want wishes to speak to
this or to
uh item or or do item item one part one
anyone from the audience
no
okay uh I see seeing nothing I will'll
go on from believe part four and we will
is go here's the bill part six which is
public use of coastal
shorelands and and Senator
Waters thank you Mr chairman if if
Senator Sherman is is not here I'm happy
to introduce this part
okay um so again thank you uh me Mr
chair members of the committee Senator
Waters District uh four um this is
really kind of a housekeeping bill um we
have changed a number of years ago the
definition of the high water uh
Mark uh and this was just one section of
law that it came to Senator Sherman's
attention that that change had not been
made so basically it's bringing this
section of law uh into Conformity with
the other parts of the law where the um
definition now is the average height of
all the high waters over a complete
title cycle commonly referred to as the
mean high tide
line so um that that's that's it really
is kind of a housekeeping but that's
does any any questions of Senator
Waters should we have one question stand
by it's uh represent span uh
representative
Spain thank you Senator Waters I was
curious about this one as soon as I saw
it and I have been um involved in this
kind of uh issue before it seems to me
that what we're doing is that we
are uh reducing the amount amount of um
of land that is going to be protected
instead of it being uh the highest water
that is seen say in storms or or the
high even the high uh Waters that we see
in the the spring and fall uh lunar
things uh high
waters all of that area will no longer
be protected now we're just going down
to the average
of the high the High Tides um is that
true that we are leaving some of that
area now
unprotected well thanks for your
question uh representative and I I I
think not really um because if you look
at this we've got the
19-year matonic ti title cycle right and
um you know that comes and goes and uh
so are you g to catch one you know
extreme high tide and have that be set
the standard but the difference between
that and the average height of all the
high waters over a complete title cycle
is really what's more meaningful here
and I will say that you know if you want
to get into the Arcana of this um this
goes back to English common law which
was adopted um in in our
Colony um to try to you know to to
negotiate in between the um you know
what what is the public uh property and
what is the private uh property and um
you know there are centuries of of work
on this um but this one I think is real
common sense it also as I said reflects
what is elsewhere in statute so I I
don't think that we are really um in any
in any way any meaningful way um
changing the amount of of uh land that
is uh covered by this follow up Mr Mr
chairman or followup yes thank you for
taking my questions Senator um at one
time wasn't the definition of and and of
course we're talking about now where the
buffer is going to start when we're
talking about buffers from from the um
Sal salt water um so it is significant
and wasn't it before the
highest um the highest Waters the
highest high tides that was
the the limit now that highest high tide
is getting absorbed in a in an average
that may not respect the amount of high
waters there are say there are three or
four very high water events
um that and they're going to get
completely U subsumes by an average so
we're losing the protection of those
highest high
waters uh particularly if there aren't
so many of them that they're beginning
average thank you um representative for
the question there and
um you know I I I again I'm not sure
that it makes much difference in terms
of practical effect in terms of where
the line is I do think that this
standard reflects the reality of the
19-year cycle and as it may over time
shift um you know and I I just not to
get into it too much but you know we are
there's the other thing is the U the the
Atlantic overturning Mariton
overturning uh which affects the speed
of the Gulf Stream and the welling up of
waters and the central Atlantic I mean
those things change over a long cycle as
well and um so there's a lot going on
out out there in the ocean but this to
me is is fairness and it's about
consistency I think it balances off the
private property owners rights with the
public interest appropriately and I also
think this is a you know more
meaningfully measurable standard to to
use and that's why it's been adopted
elsewhere great and one more Mr chairman
so the um and I for a followup for a
followup um I think in our in our
documentation of the bill you also cite
the fact that the data to support that
establishment of that line is readily
available and I think when you say that
this is going to be much easier to
implement I
agree um one the 19 year kind of bothers
me um I think you of all people know
about sea level rise and I'm wondering
if our sea level rise um is going to be
captured in 19 years or may we be having
changes that are more more gradual that
ultimately will call for higher high
high tide line in less than 19
years well thanks thanks for the
question and um we're getting a we're
getting into deep Waters
[Music]
representative um but let me let me just
say to to back up a little bit and say
you know um you know surely uh we're
projecting and we're seeing you know
some sea level rise um we're see that
that's that's been documented about 8
inches over the last century and there's
projections of more to come but whatever
that is you put on top of that the
19-year title cycle and um I just think
it's important here to have some
consistency and some durational
consistency here and yes things things
will change but you know um over the 19e
cycle the measurements will continue and
and adjustments um if there's underlying
changes in uh you know ocean current
circulation or sea level rise that those
things will be over the 19 years um you
know kind of adjusted uh as as that
cycle goes through and and I you know
I'm kind of cautious I I just think that
we we need to give some consistency we
need to let Property Owners know there's
some consistency over time that there
isn't going to be you know extreme
changes year to year that might affect
their property's value or you know the
public the public interest and that so I
I just think this seems to be to be
right uh as a as a way that we you know
measure it with consistency over time
and some certainty and transparency to
the to the property owners and to the to
the public
interest thank you for an excellent
explanation Senator
Waters are there any other questions by
members of the committee so I see no
questions I seeing no questions and no
questions from the uh
audience
nothing which case that that ends
the discussion on have one question the
audience Tom
Sherman
yes thank you uh I I apologize I've been
in committee are are you still on SB
146 uh oh yes well that we'll be there
all day okay all right I just wanted to
make sure I didn't miss my little
part uh if oh yeah whatever you have to
say um we're talking about this is item
six part six but if there's any other
items
you wish to speak on you're you're
welcome to do that too Senator Sherman
just let you know I did I did introduce
it and gave some background but uh take
it away sir no I just wanted to make
sure there were no questions mine was uh
the high water mark this was at the
request of uh the department to make
sure that we were up to date with our
defining the uh high water mark so um I
just
I appreciate Senator waters's covering
for me I just wanted to make sure
everybody was all set if there's
questions well you've heard the uh the
discussion I'm not certain when you
tuned in uh but uh We've you whatever
you want wish to say on it we appreciate
it we'd like we'd like to hear you well
this is you know this issue is is pretty
technical uh and but it really brings us
up to date um and um and standardizes
the language u in this area so uh the
mean High Watermark as you know is is an
important measure and
um uh and so I was asked to introduce
this as a way of ensuring that we are up
to date in our
statute uh with this definition so I
UMES post post oh representative post
for a question thank you yes this is for
Senator Waters um and I appreciate your
being here today and um helping us
understand this my question is would
this change insurance rates for
homeowners is that theine when you
referring to
um you know the
cost oh
I'm happy to answer that if that's okay
Senator Sherman of course yeah and and
thanks thanks for the question I'm
really glad you brought that up because
uh no it would not um the insurance
rates are determined by FEMA Maps FEMA
flood maps and uh FEMA releases those
they've been updated fairly recently and
uh that's what determines that and FEMA
is basing that on a variety of other
historical uh issues um and not on this
this particular definition
thank you very
question represent Smith sir uh
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Senator Sherman um uh your colleague
Senator Waters testified that uh the
definition of of high water mark was
changed years ago but that one of our
many many statutes was left out of when
all of the other CH statutes were
changed so am I correct in um assuming
that this is a state statute this is not
a federal definition of high water
Mark um I believe it is state but I
think it is standard I would defer to
Senator Waters if he knows the answer to
that but my understanding is this is the
accepted definition
along the at least the Eastern seab
mark and he's nodding so that would be
correct a nodding is hard to hear
Senator
wat excuse me and
um uh you know I I I I'm I'm sorry I
don't have the U hearing report from the
senate in front of us um but uh I I
believe that what Senator Sherman is
representing here is is the case and I
also believe this is pretty much the
standard if you're GNA if in State
statue you're going to do it by um high
waters this is the way to do it but
every state is a lot of states in terms
of the public interest is different are
different on this but this is what uh
done any other any other questions Spang
might have a question oh representative
question representative
Spang you're
muted there we go Senator Sherman thank
you for coming and giving me another
bite at the
Apple yeah I'm um I spend a great deal
of time on Cape Cod um and I think at
the cape like uh as in the Sea Coast
here there are a lot of legal cases that
come up about public access to high and
low water um and perhaps Senator Waters
was um was Elum Illuminating that issue
a little bit that that there may be um a
different set of regulations regarding
public access to high and low water
areas say on a
beach um and I I think that there's a
lot of confusion um among people who who
want to use speaches on where they're
allowed to be as a member of the public
and where they're not so it's not just a
matter of the property owners and where
how close to the water they can build
it's also this ongoing battle between
the public and um Beach users uh that is
affected by this
definition um and secondary I'd like to
know how uh
our regulations relate to those in other
states um I would have to on the second
question thank you for the questions I
think they're really important but I
would have to defer on the second one
because I'm not fully aware uh last time
I looked at Massachusetts it was mean
high water had a specific definition
um but I I really can't answer the
public access we've had one of the most
prominent Public Access issues in the
state here in
Ry um down at
um Saunders Point um and but that was
more of a private land public land and
and public access was eventually granted
by the Supreme Court so it was uh
but I guess what I would I would be able
to say is that these definitions are
critically important number one because
of the issues that you pointed out but
also they need to be consistent
throughout statute and that's all this
bill does is or this component of the
bill does is to make this one section
now fully consistent through uh with the
other areas as Senator Waters had said
great thank you I could offer something
on that as well is that you know just
again to reiterate representative I
don't do not think that this change here
this in this technical change in statute
has any practical effect on the public
trust shorelands area and people's
access to it to answer the other part of
your question you know you may see it in
the news um lately because of some new
lawsuits but Maine does it very
differently uh in terms of what access
is part of the public trust shorelands
and there was a main Supreme Court
decision back in 1996 which greatly
restricted Public Access and there's an
attempt now to revisit that but so as I
said other states are different but for
New Hampshire this is a
technical a technical definitional
change I don't think there's any
practical effect on public access or
public trust shorelands but it provides
some
consistency and transparency uh for
property owners and for members of the
public thank you thank
you no
further me no further
questions uh from either none from the
audience
also okay I will close the uh discussion
on uh on part six and that uh that
should be all the that should be all
that uh we have as far
as uh parts that are specific to re
resources
uh and that really takes care of the the
morning for section of session on this
bill at one o'clock we will be meeting
for part three and five parts three and
five with the help of fishing game it be
one o'clock
and
uh so that's I will there is some other
business I want to go with the go over
with the members of the committee uh but
for of course it isn't public but uh we
for now uh Senator
Waters Senator Sherman or anyone else in
the audience uh we will not be taking up
any of uh of any of Senate Bill 146
until 1 o'clock in the afternoon
so
we will not have we will not be
discussing this uh this aspects of this
bill of
106 the uh during the during the interim
so we're just going to be doing uh other
business see uh anyone who's not part of
the committee
uh you could there's you can listen but
we're not going to be doing any we the
business that we're going to be
discussing is some uh committee some
U Senate
uh Senate amendments to some uh some
bills that some house bills that we
passed uh was a house bill 115 and I
think it's 311 correct uh representative
Smith yes that is correct and
uh why don't uh you you were the prime
you were Prime on uh the with 311 or or
was it on
115 well I'm Prime sponsor on both of
them oh okay then you might as well I
might as well recognize you would you
gone actually I have my own you have
okay um so actually um House Bill uh 115
was the wake surfing bill it was the
safety bill that passed the house
unanimously went over to the Senate and
um one of the questions brought up by
one of the Senators was that the part of
the bill that said that um because of
wake surfing does not use a tow rope and
the person is directly behind the boat
um in the water that they could only use
a boat specifically designed for that
purpose and one of the Senators
questioned did we really need the word
specifically was wasn't just designed
for that purpose
enough
um Captain dun leevy said he didn't
think that would change anything as far
as enforcement went and um so I that's
the explanation of that one word was
bill anyone has any questions about it
or comments because what we'll need to
do is uh for new people um when the
Senate amends a bill that passed the
house the bill then comes back
informally to the committee where the
bill was passed originally and me
members of the committee either concur
with the change the Senate made and or
not Concur and the bill dies or not
Concur and ask for a committee of
conference um so this will something we
will be asked the committee chair will
be asked to make a motion to concur or
not um next and in one of the upcoming
uh full sessions that we have but it's
always nice to discuss these things with
the committee in case people have
so send out to
everyone side by
sides uh especially for
the for new folks it's a it's a way of
being able to see where the changes are
without having to read every every word
and keep going back and for the the
committee the committee assistant does
basically does for you and and we'll
highlight where exactly the U the
changes are and you can regly see it uh
the uh what H what the normal procedure
is it's a little a little Loosey Goosey
when it comes
to concurs nonc concurs nonring
requesting a commit of conference uh I
was surprised even somebody who been
around as long as I have uh that
actually the the the authority rest
solely with the chair as far as whether
do concur
notur confence but it's foolish to even
do it without
consulting your committee and that's
what what I'm doing now is try to get
everybody's understand understanding
what's
happening representative Smith has
explained what this the difference in
this
fill so you
see she explained it is
minuscule so a minor change and doesn't
really affect the bill Le to my tination
but I think I'd like to get concurrence
from everyone here we don't need a
formal
vote but I I'd like to have
uh
a an
affirmation a consensus from members of
the of the committee uh so what I'll do
is just simply say is there anyone who
concurring yes thank you I'm sorry are
we including um the first part also
um I see the I see the change so what
you have up on the screen is the second
part of that on the propulsion system
but if you go back to the wake surfing
issue
which um that is this if you go back to
page
one see I can't see that
okay
so where it says new paragraph voting it
says number one new paragraph voting
it's the second box down these appear to
be identical can you tell me what the
difference might be when you read this I
didn't see anything
different from the house bill to the
Senate
bill is only one word only one word yeah
so when you're looking at the um you're
first you're looking at the house bill
then you're looking at the Senate bill
and in the third column are what the
changes are so as you can see in the
third column there's no changes anywhere
except when we get down propulsion
system okay thank you for clarifying
asking any change is in the the far I
right
uh so on
the on
115 hear how about this I have any uh
any objections to to concurring
no say no
objections we will
I will I will write to the to the
clerk let them know that it is that we
will confer with
the with the Senate
311 yes so House Bill 311 was the um the
bill to form a committee to study the um
the formation and the use of rail trails
and to develop best management practices
for dealing with the surfaces or any
contaminants that could be there um when
this bill went to the
Senate It Was Heard by the
transportation
committee now in in our so-called
resources Recreation and development
committee we hear bills related to rail
trails in the Senate the transportation
committee does so
they and I agreed that the one member
being a part of the Senate energy and
natural resources committee wasn't the
appropriate Senate member and I
suggested they amend it to say it was
someone from the Transportation
committee the Senate their Infinite
Wisdom said the member could be any
member of the Senate but that member
would be appointed by the president of
the Senate so that was the only change
it was just who was going to appoint the
Senate
member and other than that the bill is
house everybody see
that I mean
uh it it would appear to me I would I
personally would wish to concur there's
uh uh any any uh any opposition to that
any concerns on that uh no hands raised
sir okay there's no hands I I will take
that to mean that we on House Bill
311 that we will we we will concur with
the changes of the that the Senate have
made and what will happen now is I will
let this let let the clerk of the house
know and uh and we'll
then uh it this will be
taken care of at the next time we have a
uh a session which will probably
be in this in the in in the future can't
be in the it isn't going to be now and
later I can't I can't tell you when
exactly but it will be held it has to be
in a in a uh in a public
session in a house session so being that
I think uh we're that's all the business
I have but we'll meet we can break for a
little long
o'clock is there a question who has a
pen someone have a hand up I was waving
goodbye oh all
right all right we're going
on all
right
for
what
mute we have eight
attendees oh
attendees we didn't have
a well we got fishing game but not
Representatives uh so that one right
me
yeah
Che
go down the camera should be on you
should see oure room as
well all I've got is just a name it just
say
sure best
[Music]
I
just
[Music]
is
name know
that
I no I didn't think you could actually
than I don't I don't
think see anybody
n no but um is R Harvey go in your clerk
right The Zo the name of each should
speaking screen is so far away I know I
know
it would be a you had cameraman like
yeah my
phone all right what are you saying
representative okay just ask me a
[Music]
lunch
do you want me to join into the R&D am I
taking
control gonna run it good okay here to
ask questions and listen
[Music]
leave
interfere
exactly mine is still connected to our
regular one with the recess till
two okay mess up I don't want to
that
open
go
diseases no no that's ours to
Wildlife tell me that the reason I
thing
and
[Music]
Mr CH did you tell might have some fish
game members
the over there there two on attendees
that promoted they don't need to be
promoted unless they they're okay it's
fine just let them do his thing thank
you
Dy yeah so Harvey and llam are on the
right okay back in the
room now 1
o' rise Standard
hearing
section 146 sections three and five
parts
that have to do with expertise that
R doesn't have that much of but Fish
game has a lot of
game joining
us
with let me turn first turn my mic on
um to pick up the way we uh we had uh uh
ra the hearing had gone in the morning
uh I will be
recognizing the uh first I'll I'll
obviously recognize the
uh Senator Waters and who will introduce
the the the part of the part of the
parts of the bill will be discussing but
I will uh the first people I will
recognize for questions uh will be
members of fishing game because they
have the expertise and can get a started
off at a a level that uh that so that
our R&D folks can uh can you
know can learn from from their from
their their questioning and then uh
after they're finished I would then open
the questioning for to members of R R&D
and we'll and that's the cycle that
we'll go through uh when in questioning
the those giving
testimony uh any questions on that by
anyone if uh so I will uh ask Senator
waters are you ready yes and uh thank
you Mr chairman and uh good to see again
members of resources Recreation and
development and also um great to see
chairman Lang and members of fishing
game I'm always glad to be back before
my home committee from when I was in the
in the house so I'm Senator David Waters
uh from District 4 and I'm introducing
part three of Senate Bill
146 and this part uh deals with the
prevention of zoonotic disease
transmission and certainly we've heard
way too much about these and the
consequences that we're all living under
these These Days uh so this is a bill
that helps us be prepared and uh it lets
us be prepared and to monitor things but
also takes a couple practical steps that
we can take right now to uh keep people
and uh
livestock uh safe in the state of State
of New
Hampshire um the key the core of the
bill uh is in um section three New
Hampshire needs to prepare for the
emergency and management of Novel
xonotic pathogens that may threaten
Public Health Food security biological
diversity and economic um security and
the reason we need to do this is that
while there are some controls over the
importation
of uh of species that might carry
xonotic diseases under sites that's the
uh convention on international trade and
endangered species um that that Federal
Regulation it just regulates endangered
species and also as we learned when we
did the wildlife trafficking laws a
couple years ago um the federal
government just does uh interstate and
they don't do any enforcement regulation
within the state and that's why we need
to keep an eye on what's Happening uh
here so the first part of the um Bill
essentially um gets the director of Fish
and Game to monitor available
information on animals and fish and as
these May emerge and uh in so doing you
know consult with Health and Human
Services um State veterinarian um
scientific institutions just as a way of
keeping an eye on what may be emerging
in New Hampshire and uh and elsewhere
and I want to thank um particularly uh
director of fishing game Mason and Paul
Sanderson and fishing game and also uh
Commissioner of Agriculture Jasper who
really helped so much in bringing to
this bill to a point that'll work for
New Hampshire and this is one of those
important um important points here is
that the fishing game director then can
keep an eye on this and if something
emerges can recommend to the legislature
legislation or rules but I think in
light of what we've recently seen
perhaps even more importantly is to say
to the governor hey we've got to have
some emergency action on um what is
potentially um emerging the second part
of the bill um takes some practical
steps that we can do now to make sure
that uh our live animal markets don't
become perhaps the the sources for these
disease uh vectors so you get some
definitions here which um are meant to
you provide Clarity of just what uh
we're covering in live animal markets
and then um you'll see down around line
11 it's just do this Common Sense
regulation uh that if you have an animal
that is been
identified uh that a taxon known to be
likely responsible for CTIC
transmission um then it should not be
offered for sale in a market um then
secondly um Wildlife species that are
identified as such should not be
caged uh or transported with livestock
or domestic animals because you know it
can get into that that uh pool of of uh
animals and um that's not as that that's
not good um
either and um then uh a little bit
further on um as I mentioned cites and
endangered species and Wildlife
trafficking um there are some species
that just aren't covered under those
that we want to make sure are not being
offered for sale because they can
transmit
diseases bats need I say um rodents or
primate species are ones that we can
make sure right now that we're not going
to have in live animal uh
markets and then um as is appropriate
rules will be adopted um governing a
store and sale of animals and life live
animal uh markets and live Wildlife uh
markets and then really important the
exceptions um that we have here just to
make sure that um this has no impact
whatsoever on current livestock
markets uh or the offer of sale of
livestock that are currently allowed
under New Hampshire law so this is
completely outside of it doesn't doesn't
affect that same thing with shellfish so
you want to get your Lobster you want
want to get your your oysters or you
want to get your chickens or your or
your beef um this does not uh affect
affect that and then there are a couple
penalties there that uh seem rather
rather appropriate um of course written
warning first usually would would
suffice and if someone continues to
violate then there'd be a fine as well
so I don't know if we had any former boy
scouts out there Girl Scouts but be
prepared be prepared and I think this is
just some common sense and simple simple
things we can do and again my many
thanks to um director Mason and to
commissioner Jasper for um helping
create a bill that everybody thinks is a
good idea for New Hampshire uh thank you
questions chairman Lang like take over
for having putting some questions from
your committee great thank you I will do
that thank you Mr chairman um I'll start
off with a couple questions of my own if
you don't mind Senator um so I I'm looks
like this bill allows for three
potential actions to be taken if an
animal is deemed to to uh be able to do
this transmission one of which is
legislation one of which is rules and
the third one with it is an emergency
order uh with the governor and my my
concern is around two things number one
timing legislations we know could take
over a year to get through the house or
Senate and act
um rules I think the shortest process
for rules is about three to six months
if you really tighten things up and so
the last one that's left is for an act
for immediate action if we decide that
it's necessary is an emergency order but
I think that would to do an emergency
order you'd have to have a declaration
of emergency under 4 colon 45 so I'm
wondering whether that last section
should read executive order versus
emergency order thank you Mr chairman I
I I thank so much for that for catching
that you're absolutely right about that
and um you know I I think that's our
fail safe here uh given what you said
about legislative process that if
something's got to be done it's got to
be done fast huh um and I saw emergency
order really is what it excuse me
executive order is what it should say on
your other points about how we can act I
mean of course it is that is true but um
right now we can do the rul making on
the um markets and uh that that is
something can be done and you know we
we're not in a situation right now that
you know that there's immediately a
problem has to be addressed so that Ru
making can take place again so that it
would be in place you know say if next
year something came up um that we would
we would need need that of course part
of the bill that says the prohibiting
the importation of these taxons will
take effect upon upon passage so um you
know the bill is meant to address the
future as much as it is to give some
Authority right now to figure out what's
going on and get some action if we need
it thank you Senator representative
Spain has a question thank you Mr chair
thank you senator for taking the
question um in that same vein of of uh
questioning there's nothing that
prohibits the legislature from going
ahead and enacting a law anyway so the
only part of this that's actually
applicable is that the department would
make a recommendation of a law that is
uh necess Neary and again that's a long
process is that is that
correct um thanks for the question well
uh you know I guess it's it's partly an
issue of timing as always that if
something is happening right now the the
um fishing game director is the one
who's going to be monitoring that
getting the
reports um through the various networks
from Health and Human Services um where
that information comes from this is the
director becomes the person who can um
see what's going on and then uh make
recommendations now it might be
immediate action and that's the
executive order but it also might be is
that we have it seems as if there's a
species that um may be emerging as a
risk and maybe we ought to um do that or
as time goes by if it looks like there
developments in um live animal markets
that we hadn't anticipated um but that
are not an immediate emergency
legislation could be recommended the
second part of the bill right now on
live animal markets though I think does
some stuff we' we've got to do right now
um we got to make sure you know bats and
rodents and some others are not being
sold I think we have to right now it' be
pretty smart to make sure we're not
transporting uh these taxons with
domestic
animals um so these are things I think
again we you know better safe than sorry
and we can do this now
followup represent thank you Mr chair
yeah I have a followup and it did touch
on that other section you were talking
about um I actually um I don't know from
coming from the fishing game department
I I kind of wish that agriculture was in
on this one as well because I do not
know um what the livestock markets
currently allow to be sold alive whether
that includes uh foul like chickens or
consumption and such um and I assume
that gentic disease would also include
mad cow disease which could be
considered something that's not on a
wildlife situation and necessarily our
our fish and game director wouldn't
catch that it would be the agriculture
director who would catch that so I kind
of wish that that we had some bleed into
the agriculture department on some of
these aspects for the wet markets or or
um live animal markets as they're called
here um am I correct that life mad cow
disease transmissible from animal to
human would be considered under this
category
and um do you have any insight as to
what animals currently allowed in those
those
markets thanks for the question and um
you know I I did have a lot of
conversation with commissioner Jasper on
this and um I'm sure he would welcome a
call and so I I'll try to remember that
and actually you know um Paul Sanderson
I believe is on the call he's provided
on the test on the hearing and I think
he and I know he's provided some
testimony and he was on his
conversations as well so he may be able
to be a little more thorough on this um
but you know the livestock markets um we
have you know for the most part slaugher
houses are are where most um of most
animals get processed and we have a
system of that and inspection system and
the um commissioner Jasper Jasper is
very confident about about that um and
then on a mad cow disease as well I
think there there are currently testing
and procedures and protocols about that
God forbid if it should uh if it should
appear um here um I think what we're
trying to capture are some of the
smaller places smaller
markets um take out you know places that
that uh that there may be some live
animals that are being that are being
sold and and uh slaughtered on premise
and that's what we're trying to catch
here to make sure that we have have
regulation on that um that it makes it
very explicit down below that
essentially saying everything that's in
those exemptions about livestock are
saying yeah agriculture's taking care of
that um and the shellfish markets and
things yeah fishing game's already taken
care of that but these live markets as
they're defined in the definition
sections are what we we want to make
sure because as we all know um that's
where not only are these you know that
that it's not only in you know in
overseas we've seen this um but you know
they are pretty substantial live animal
markets in some cities in United States
and uh not too far from here and um you
know the anticipation is that we
probably ought to make sure we're ready
if they start to become more prevalent
in New
Hampshire so I hope that gets at it
that'ss it Representatives plane but um
you know I I'm commissioner Jasper would
be glad to talk to thank
you represent I'd also direct your
attention to page six of the bill around
area line 21 which gives the Department
of Agriculture culture certain amount of
Ru making authority to help manage this
process right right thank you for that
Mr
chairman uh represent Reed nothing
represent Reed has nothing is there
anybody from the fishing game committee
room um that would like to speak and if
so someone needs to unmute and then
representative uh Vice chair bull if you
could call out the name of the
speak any member wants to
speak we are good over here no no no oh
ahead no I'm saying you can go ahead and
speak can you hear me from here I think
so yeah can you hear me from here I can
just make sure you state your name so we
know who's
representative I read the I read that
section
three I noted that you said no sale of
live markets with rodents and uh and
primates well those are very commonly uh
test animals as there already Provisions
in the Hampshire law for providing these
animals to uh Laboratories in state for
experimentation uh thank you for your
question um there is statute govering
that already and but more more
particularly um that is governed by
research protocol
uh that are you know having taught at
UNH for a long time although my
experiment was in an English Department
so my live experiments were on students
not on primates or another kind of
primate um but uh that that aside um
there are very very stringent guidelines
um governing uh La laboratory research
uh that um govern that thank you may I
have a followup
followup thank you um how many uh how
many of these live markets exist do we
know that they you know is this is this
actually a problem
here well thanks for the question um you
know the reports that we've had again
maybe um Paul sander can can speak to
this that there there are there are some
stores that that sell that have live
animals um there are some markets that
this might be going on um there is a
sense because of various populations uh
increasing in New England and New
Hampshire that um appreciate um being
able to get live animals um that these
may be growing um and that's fine I mean
you know if if if appropriately
regulated that's that's consumer Choice
um but we just want to make sure that if
they're there that we're making sure
these um these taxons that might be
zoonotic disease transmissible are it's
that it becomes very clear that no oh th
those can't be those those can't be
present so um you know again is you know
the the markets the mark some markets
are there but um let's be sure that we
that we make sure we keep them safe
thank you Senator is there anybody else
in the fishing game room that wishes to
ask a question of the senator we have uh
Mr serson will be testifying next so if
your question is more appropriate you
might want to hold it for
him so I see no further questions
question
sand is there anyone from any questions
Comm questions
no no
senator Paul Sanderson available yes
thank you I hope you can hear me at this
point we can hear you we can hear you
well thank you uh this is Paul Sanderson
I'm the legal coordinator of the fish
and game department uh in addition to
our written testimony I would like to
thank Senator waters for his leadership
on this particular issue and I will try
to deal with a couple of points that
have been raised in discussion so far um
we are talking about a codification of
proes that already somewhat exist
cooperation between the fish and game
department the Department of
Environmental Services the Department of
Health and Human Services and the
Department of
Agriculture uh the advantage of this is
it really codifies our process and uh
gives us a clear road map of things to
do in the event these issues are
detected um when I when people have
asked some questions about how these
things actually work in practice we have
haven't had a zootic question recently
but we did have a recent issue of an
invasive species uh where we had uh
importation into the state um of zebra
muscles that were involved in certain uh
materials that were sold in pet stores
and I wish to give you really the
success story of cooperation between the
various departments and how that was
dealt with the information originally
came from the US fish and wildlife
Service uh communication occurred
between all four departments uh pet
stores are regulated by the Department
of
Agriculture uh and so what we were able
to do was identify the offensive
material that contained the invasive
Zebra muscles work with Private Industry
to have them understand what these uh
particular uh invasive species were uh
bring them under control control and
caused them to be destroyed in such a
way that they were not going to be uh an
issue for our state it was a model of
cooperation between the
Departments and so I what I want to do
is just give you some comfort that in
fact these lines of communication exist
uh when an issue presented itself that
required some immediate action we were
able to obtain the cooperation of
Private Industry uh because they also
did not want to see any sort of release
of these invasive uh species and uh the
system worked so uh we very much
appreciate the efforts of the senator to
bring this to everyone's attention uh it
helps us to continue on with our
existing communicative processes but the
system does exist and it does work uh
with that in mind I'd be happy to answer
any other questions that you might have
for
me thank you thank you uh Paul um
representative Spain has a question for
you thank you Mr chair thank you uh Paul
um long time no here um I am looking at
line 27 where it talks about the the
chapter shall not prohibit seafood or
shellfish markets or the sale or offer
of sale of seafood or shellfish that are
currently allowed under the Hampshire
law and I'm just wondering because I
don't know off the top of my head how
Fish and Game classifies
freshwater um fish species um and or
things such as
escargo and other species that may be
consumed may be sold live for
consumption but don't fall under uh
something that was caught in um sea for
seafood or um is not a
shellfish okay um those are oftentimes
with Inland species uh are materials
that are used for bait for Inland
fishing and we definitely regulate them
as bait
uh we regulate their importation their
possession and their use and in fact we
license bait dealers so once again if we
determine that there are problems with
them such as invasive species we're able
to interact uh immediately and work on
that we do have rules in our chapter FIS
800 that allow our various divisions to
engage in situations such as
that follow up follow up um thank you Mr
chair thank you again Paul um so if if
what if the fish is not being sold for
bait say what if a
um fish is this happens to be a
freshwater species of say catfish or um
a
freshwater uh crawfish that's going to
be
eaten uh again it's a matter of
cooperation between departments if there
becomes a public health question as to
whether this would cause harm to humans
in the matter of consumption we work
with the Department of of Health and
Human Services to maintain the safety of
human
health
okay all right is there anybody in the
fishing game uh committee room that
would like to ask a question or a
fishing game member that's attending
remotely if we do um Vice chairman Abul
is there anybody in the room would like
to ask a question Mr chairman I do have
one representative go ahead uh Mr
Sanderson thank you for taking my
question question is I understand that
most of the product like consumer
product like meat beef or chicken comes
from out of state is it going to be a
mark on the package that is New
Hampshire
standard uh to the extent that material
comes from out of state uh the movement
interstate is controlled by the federal
department of Agriculture and the State
Department of Agriculture for those
particular species and so uh nothing in
this particular particular bill would
change that current system of
Regulation thank
you thank you representative con um is
there anybody else in the committee room
speak I don't see anybody
representa there any members from
s there are no questions is there anyone
in
the the
audience wishes to testify in this
of No Hands Up I no hands up so I we can
move on then from second three
additional questions or concerns I think
we're ready for Section Five Mr chairman
all
right
water for SE five thank you again Mr
chairman and then members of the
committee Senator David Waters uh
District
4 um this bill is a reintroduction of a
bill from last year which passed the
Senate unanimously and then got uh
cized and um let me just explain a
little bit of the background um here uh
it tries to address the growing issue of
der fishing gear traps trap Parts rope
buoys foam microplastics and so on um
which all can be the source of of ocean
Plastics and also create um
navigational hazards uh there's um been
increasing concern about this and we
focused quite a bit on the issue uh on
the commission on Marine natural
resources uh an environment uh and we
had several reports um you know from
people concerned about ocean Plastics
and then also uh folks in the fishing
Community about the problems arising
from der uh gear on the ocean bottom um
so working with Eric Anderson who I may
have submitted testimony or may be
available to testify representing the
fisherman has proposed in the in that
commission that we try to come up with a
way uh to help fund the clean clean up
efforts uh on um on derel fishing
fishing gear and you know just to to
sketch in some of the issues that can be
raised um the ocean Plastics uh show up
in the marine environment but then they
also show up in aquatic species um we're
seeing them uh in fish we're seeing
beginning to see them in shellfish and
um there is evidence now that they are
then showing up in human beings um who
eat the fish and even in um in in uh in
in utero in fetuses that uh these
Plastics are showing up and they can do
all kinds of things with the endocrine
system and and um you know potentially
past and other things as well so it's
good to reduce them um the other thing
is the na the
navigational um Hazard you know we might
have some discussion later about uh gear
balls and what they are is that with the
ocean action over time that the the gear
traps and anything can form these really
large balls and then not only might they
be a a hindrance to navigation but also
if you're trying to you know fish and
troll or drag your nets uh you're going
to run into one of these things and and
be in a big mess um so far what we've
had is the coastal trap cleanup day a
voluntary annual event and so far has
gotten 156 tons of fishing gear off the
coastline which is great for people you
know recreating on the beaches but also
um great for the environment uh as well
now this event costs uh it's $1,300 to
$2,500 for the heavy equipment um this
has been largely funded by a grant
program of late um we also have a
fishing for energy program which puts
out uh 30 yard rollof dumpster down at
the Yankee Fisherman's Co-op so the
fishing Community has a place to dump um
its its gear and that's Sly important
because municipalities don't want to
take this for recycling anymore um but
there is a company down in Mass usit who
will Who will take it um and uh and and
be able to recycle um that but that too
costs and so with the potential loss of
that grant funding that's on a time
schedule it's going to run out um we
thought that this might be a way to to
take care of that and it's you know
something again worked very closely with
the fishing game and um with the fishing
community on it and so to turn to the to
the bill itself it does a couple of
things it sets up a um derc fishing gear
fund uh and uh then into that fund um
lit control penalties for people who are
dumping on the beach or there is a
penalty if you if you um dump fishing
gear um that that that those fines could
go into the uh into the fund um and then
for a certain set of licenses uh if
you're a license holder then the fishing
game director could set a sarch charge
between 10 and
$25 um and that would be deposited in
the fund now I have provided the
committee with an amendment um we had
another meeting with Eric Anderson
yesterday in fishing game um and he
pointed out a couple of things number
one is that the we have included here
the shrimp license um but we've really
lost Northern shrimp in the Gulf of
Maine uh the last four years um the
biomass seems to be moving north um and
maybe diminishing some because of the
warming uh of the Gulf of main you it's
one of the fastest warming bodies in the
world and that that biomass just moving
to colder colder water so um and that
fishery has been pretty much closed by
the Atlantic states marine fisheries
commission so it makes no sense at all
here because nobody's doing the fishing
to have that
included the other thing was pointed out
is that it also included the urchins and
scalloping and there are very very few
uh people who um are in that in that
industry right now either so what the
amendment does it takes out the shrimp
and then it says I mean the heart of
this bill is that okay you've got the
sear charge but if you participate in a
cleanup activity you don't pay you don't
pay and what's great about this is that
and why the fishermen were interested in
the bill was that it's going to
encourage more
participation and uh get the work done
and hopefully have people be a little
more responsible about their about their
their gear um but if you do that you
don't pay and so it'll be most of the
out of state folks um who end up paying
the sear charge uh because of our
agreements with the states we can't just
say we're going to charge a sear charge
and out of Staters you know won't get
very far with that but this is a way of
doing it so that New Hampshire people if
they don't want to pay they have to pay
um you know one example Eric Anderson
get well you know okay so there's maybe
a person who's kind of a hobbyist gets a
you know recreational license and has a
few traps um but they're not going to be
bothered to come to the cleanup well
they okay they'll pay their 10 bucks um
but for a lot of the people who are in
who are actively fish fishing they
already show up and um there'll be a
variety of ways that the director is
going to develop
so that you know all kinds of
participation so even if you can't make
the cleanup day that's okay there be
another way you can help participate in
this and so you won't have to won't have
to pay so then just to go down through
the uh as you can just see in the um
details of the of the bill then uh it
simply repeats that um in various places
the uh sech charge on the various
licenses that I have uh I have
mentioned um and then down
towards the end um you get to the um the
fishing gear Coastal cleanup and fishing
for energy
fund and uh here uh that fund is set up
and we wanted to make particularly clear
to the
industry that um this fund is going to
go for this
purpose and it's going to be trans
parent there's reporting on
it uh and so you know the fishermen are
always keeping an eye on a dollar and
they want to make sure that they're if
they're they're paying it's not getting
sucked into into other purposes so we
did a lot to try to provide some
reassurances around that and then the
other question was raised by um that
well what if you know the fund starts to
build up and um you know there's plenty
of money uh well the director fishing
game has the um option here to decide
not to collect it or to reduce reduce
the amount so I think those are some
kind of transparency and assurances on
the creation of that of that fund um it
would not only take the sear charges but
if we do get some grants um the fines
would come into this as well and so this
would let us keep going and keep our
keep our coasts clean and also help out
the fishermen and get the gear off the
bottom so um thank you uh members of the
commit committees and and the chairs and
got to take any
questions thank you Senator I have a a
question to start off with um so I'm
looking at the last section of this bill
the derel fishing gear Coastal cleanup
and the last one kind of stumps me and
fishing for energy fund and I'm trying
to understand what fishing for energy
fund has to do with this is I as I read
the bill it talks about retrieving and
disposing of derel gear and conducting
dose tolea programs uh uh of and removal
of der like gear and Marine trash and
then work in supporting the recycling
for this fund but I I'm trying to
understand what ises fishing for energy
mean oh thanks for that question uh
chairman and um I I should have I should
have made it explicit earlier I I
mentioned that Yankee Fisherman's Co-op
dumpster um that that's a program that's
the fishing for uh for energy program
and um what they do is they take that
dumpster when it's filled they take it
down to their their plant in
Massachusetts and they they um they
trans form those materials into um into
fuels that can be used so great you know
it's just it's a great recycling plant
it costs us to have the dumpster and to
transport it down there and uh but
that's that's that's why that's there so
that's it's it's referen to that
existing program at the Yankee
Fisherman's Co-op and and that's real
popular too you know the fisherman
having a place to to to dump their gear
and doesn't cost them anything that's
good repr blade as a question thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Senator Waters
um I have a question and a followup um
but my first question has to do with
timing I love the idea but from a
somebody most people who purchase their
license annually probably of the of time
when the cleanup takes place so I
imagine that they would have had to have
proof of participating in the cleanup
the prior year to get the waved fees on
the current Year's license or is that a
rebate back to them after they've
purchased their license and paid the fee
and then participated in the cleanup how
does that work because the timing
doesn't seem to really work out unless
it's a fisherman that fishes every year
and you start them out with um you know
a gift of don't do it don't pay it the
first
year yeah uh you know we it's a great
question thank you for it representative
we tried to I I I think we tried to
address it in the bill in terms of the
ru making that the uh the director is
going to have on it um because that
that's the point we did not want to have
people have to pay the first year you
notice it goes into effect January 1st
2022 and um some people buy their
licenses right at the start some people
uh buy them later on but the idea is
that the commissioner would have excuse
me the director would have ways to
recognize
participation um so that that doesn't
that doesn't have to be paid the first
year that's the intent of the bill and
uh maybe Paul Sanderson will have some
further thoughts on that but um we we
talked about that a lot and the intent
of the bill is to say if you from the
get-go you won't have to you won't have
to
pay follow up follow up um thank you and
uh Senator Waters my followup is
actually a question on that fund um you
mentioned that it should the fund become
well funded that the director has the
options of not collecting the fee or um
you know reducing the fee was there any
thought given to redirecting allowing
fishing game to have the ability to
redirect monies into fishery habitat
Rehabilitation and um prevention of of
uh declination of species um because I
believe the fishermen would probably be
all in favor of that well thanks for
your question and uh I will tell you I
think you'll hear otherwise from the
fishermen uh that they they really you
know they really want to know if they're
paying this for Dar gear that's what's
going to now one answer I would have to
the potential for the fund to grow
larger is that there are a lot of things
we could do and could pay for we're not
doing now so you know the amount there
that uh I mentioned you know $ 1,300
$2500 for the heavy equipment and the
dumpsters for the annual cleanup day yes
but we the other big problem is those um
those gear balls and right now you know
if the Coast Guard and the fishing game
divers and vessels are available and
have some time and one's been
identified they can go out and retrieve
it but this fund would also provide some
funding to get to do that work and that
that costs you know um you're talking
about divers and things but um that
that's that's a big problem that now
could be addressed that isn't being
addressed so I I kind of think that the
the the director will pick a a low
amount like the $10 and that that'll do
it that we that'll pretty well balance
things out as uh as time goes
by thank you thank you represent Spain
thank you Senator uh there's no other
people in the room with a question is
there anybody the fishing game committee
room or remotely that would like to ask
a question regarding this fund
representative
Howard I'm sorry representative go ahead
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
for taking my question
[Music]
Senator this is this going to affect a
recreational saltwater fishing license
is this going to be attached to that
too it's in there
yes
any further questions from the committee
room I do have a question uh Mr chairman
just state your name so we can hear it
nice and
clearly that's Khan this is
representative Khan I represent also the
same district where the Yankee fisherman
is located CBR and thank you senator for
taking my question the question is uh
you mentioned that the grant or the
funding is going to be over very soon
how soon I like to see that that program
that Yankee fisherman Coop does or all
the fisherman does clean up a day once a
year um I like to see that that going
you know any possible way when that
funding is going to be over and I have a
followup
too thanks for the question if I may
take a moment I made a mistake just a
moment ago um it's the non-resident
commercial saltwater license and the
resident commercial salt saltwater
license so I'm sorry I gave the uh
mistaken answer about the regular
saltwater license it's the commercial
ones that are here so I wanted to
correct that um I'm I think Paul
Sanderson have some more information I
think the grant is running down in the
next couple
years um and that's that's that's why
this is not a bad time to get this
started so if we start it next year um
we'll be able to transition out of that
out of that anant and um keep the
program going because as you said it's
important down there at Yankee
Fisherman's Co-op it
is follow up follow up Senator um in Ian
Fishman for most of the
members it's not New Hampshire residents
I understand you know being there for
many years and I also served as a super
Board of Select uh if they do not live
in New Hampshire they have to pay
more uh no it's it's it's a flat
there'll be a flat search charge but if
you you know whether you live in
Hampshire or out of state if you come
and participate in the cleanup you don't
have to
pay thank you
Senator anybody else from the committee
question seeing none hearing none um I
will turn it back over to you Mr
J any
questions
resources I see no questions from the
resource
committee Eric Anderson has his hand
recogniz
about about fines for dumping are
already already exist uh where did they
go to now
they don't they would go into this fund
correct yeah thanks for the question
it's basically under the littering
statute I mean we have a littering
statute that covers all kinds of things
and um it just says that uh if it's
Coastal littering that the fines
collected under that existing law will
here thanks for the question anybody
else from the
committee
Mr Anderson okay Mr Anderson a question
or excuse me actually Mr Anderson cannot
question Mr
Anderson I was going to take Mr
Sanderson uh yes thank you
um usurp anytime from uh Eric Anderson
uh who has given generously of his time
to attend our hearing so uh if he would
like to make any particular comments I
would certainly defer to him and remain
in the meeting to answer your questions
after he's
concluded right okay with you Mr
Anderson are you
there Eric
Anderson can you hear
me uh yes you
can yes good afternoon thank you very
much uh Mr chairman and um just to
testify in favor of this bill we've um
discussed it in you know the in the det
detail that I think has been stated by
Senator Waters um and then I think the
reasons and the rational is to try and
build um a fund that's going to continue
this i' I've been involved with this
clinic for 27 years and um and and I
think it's a it's a worthy event that we
don't want to um
uh have um concluded because of um some
monetary issues that have to be intended
to and right now I think there's I I I
think the scope of it extended out to
860 licenses in the state of New
Hampshire um that would be subject to
this this fee approximately 60 to 80
fishermen annually show up um and it and
it bothers a lot of fishermen that that
90% of the fishermen that show up they
don't they none of their gear is
involved in this in this cleanup
and and um and it's just to try and
identify to give credit to the fishermen
that do show up and then to um um have
fishermen that don't show up who who
whose gear we collect have them make a
contribution to the effort um monetarily
so that we can keep it going and and um
we would like 860 lenses to show up uh
we we do it annually we um
um we collect a lot of material a lot of
De a lot of gear that comes to Shore and
and and and we do it responsibly um and
I think so many components of this bill
is is going to um keep it going um from
a fiscal perspective and um I I won't go
on I I think I think Senator Waters is
represented the bill and adjusted the
bill correctly we feel confident with
that it's in a dedicated fund that won't
you know deviate from its purpose and
um I take I you know I'd answer any
questions if any of the um if if anybody
has any um but we'd be in favor of this
bill anybody from fishing game have
Anderson hearing and seeing none thank
you Mr Anderson for your testimony I'm
sorry does Rd have any questions for Mr
Anderson
repres Smith representative Smith
question yes thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr Anderson for taking my
question um this sounds like an an
excellent um opportunity to clean up and
uh so listening to you and from the
senator and from Mr Sanderson I would I
just want to confirm with you that the
fishermen are in support of this sech
charge
yes I mean we we feel that you know for
the amount of people that that that do
show up it's it's a concern every year
for those that don't and and like I said
a
lot 90% 90% of the people that show up
to clean up it's not their gear it's not
they're cleaning up somebody else's gear
that's come ashore and and um if if it
it frustrates the people that do show up
to say why aren't the people that have
gear here why aren't they why why aren't
they doing it it's I I don't want to get
into some of the semantics of it but I
in in in general I I the industry would
support the fact that um you know this
search charge is going to keep keep keep
this program funded for the fiscal
issues that it has to has to accomplish
I think that's important if there if
those fiscal issues aren't attended to
then we don't know what would you know
we don't know what would take
place thank
you thank you uh Mr Anderson what uh uh
this is Chairman Rulo uh you represent
uh what
organization the New Hampshire
commercial Fisherman's Association New
Hampshire
commercial Fisherman's Association
yes sir okay thank you very much uh any
more questions for uh Mr
Anderson there are no no further
questions thank you Mr Anderson for your
testimony uh back to uh Mr
Sanderson PA yes thank you Mr chairman
I'm here ready to answer any questions
you would like to
pose is there any more you think we
anything more you wish to say relative
to uh uh only to express our thanks to
Mr Anderson for the time uh and
attention that he's given to this issue
today thank you Paul uh members from
fish represent Spain thank you
um Paul uh thank you for taking my
question um do you have a better answer
to the timing situation that I had asked
Senator Waters as far as how Fisherman's
going to buy their license and prove
that they participated when they may be
participating later in the year than the
license purchase happens um will it be a
refund or or
what uh thank you for the question we're
expecting that in our rulemaking process
uh we understand here that the intent of
the legislature is perfectly clear and
that we'll make provision in these
initial rule sets to provide credit to
people who have provided services to the
program in the year prior uh to the uh
rules being adopted so that we can make
sure that people are not penalized for
the efforts and support that they have
provided followup question represent
Spain thank you Mr chair and my followup
question uh PA would be um we heard some
information from Senator Waters that
there were some amendments to remove the
shrimp and uh and
the what was it uh C urin and scholer
and such I do not see that kind of
amendment here in front of me and I'm
just wondering is it a committee
Amendment let me help help with that uh
we did receive that Amendment received
it about two minutes to nine when we
started this morning so okay so so uh we
I personally haven't even read it yet
okay so but that's supported by Fish
game uh yes it was uh representative
Spain we worked on this yesterday
directly with with Mr Anderson and also
with Senator Waters uh and we fully
support his proposed amendment so so
it'll it will be some it will be sent
sent to you s to the whole committee
we'll talk we're gonna go to the next
meeting yep um anybody in the fishing
Sanderson seeing and hearing none I'll
turn it back over to you Mr chairman for
your committee questions all right
anyone from resources have a question
Sanderson there being none I'm sorry I
just want to ask one more goe I
apologize Mrs Sanderson I was thought
you were GNA get away pretty safe but I
just want to confirm this does not have
to deal with recreational licenses the
strictly commercial licenses we're
talking about and the commercial the
people who have uh who get those
commercial license support support this
program correct uh correct on both
accounts yes thank you question thank
you Che thank
you all
right seeing no addition say no further
questions I think we can say we are done
with part five and that
is it for Senate Bill uh one well uh 146
at least as it came to the committee
there will be uh at 3:00 we'll be
talking about a non gerain Amendment
which to add uh but for now uh I thank
the the fishing game committee and
chairman and folks brought with them the
helping helping us out and you I presume
are going to be having some work session
on we're going right to a work session
now hopefully we'll have a
recommendation for you by the end of the
day oh well if if you wanted to go even
beyond that and need to call a work
session need help I know the system
requires it to go through Rd have to
help that
you
right I think what uh we are we do we
have to get together for uh for just a
at 3 o'clock because that's when it is
uh when it is uh on the U on the agenda
so it's been noticed for 3:00 the it's a
small amendment that we have to put
together that we have that
representative Smith has has drafted and
all it does is it's a it's all it does
is change a date and it's so but we but
since it's noticed for 3 o'l we'll have
to have have it at
3:00 uh it all it requires is one person
to be here and I'll be here so if you
you but I you know if you want to if you
want to show up at 3 o'clock I
appreciate it uh but uh for the for
hearing purposes I mean it it's I I can
I will I can do I can stay here but I
think I'll need representative Katon
so at any rate uh we are adjourned until
3:00 or not adjourned we're recessed
o'
y
55 all right J later oh okay that clock
clock
[Music]
turn
it's 259
[Music]
rise Standard Time right big companies
own
everything
R uh actually we have to it is part of a
amendment
have this bill it is now three o'clock
all right reconvening the uh
a meeting on House Bill
146 uh excuse me Senate Bill
146 and uh we're going to be this just
uh had the hearing on
Amendment uh
number 1098 H uh representative Smith
prepared the amendment uh yes I am
so can you speak to the amendment please
okay for the record I'm Suzanne Smith I
represent the towns of Plymouth Hein and
holderness Grafton County District 8 and
I am here as the prime sponsor of this
amendment and hope that the committee
will choose to amend uh add it on to uh
house uh Senate Bill
146 um just to give a little bit of a
background uh Senate Bill 257 passed the
leg legislature and became law in
2019 and it prohibited the use of
firefighting Foams which contain peror
alcal chemicals or
pasos and part of the bill was that Dees
was required to Institute a takeback
program of these phones for the purpose
of safe and contained disposal now this
of course passed in late
2019 and uh the Bill the law states that
they must begin the takeback program
July 1st of
2021 as we all know as uh Senator Waters
called it co
cized I think that's what he said anyway
and um so things really slowed down in
the beginning of 2020 and are just now
getting back to normal both a Dees and
at all the places that might have these
Foams uh that they are storing so uh
this amendment comes at the request of
Dees and the only thing that it does is
change it extends the date uh the time
frame of the takeback program from July
2021 until July 1
2023 and I can try to answer questions
but I am hoping that Mike whims from
Dees is here or Rosemarie rung who also
was instrumental in getting this
amendment
drafted is there any questions for
representative
none question seeing none is there is
there anyone from Dees mik Mike whimet
um Mike whimet are you are you
available I am am indeed thank you Mr
chairman um thank you for being
recognized so um thanks to
representative Smith for uh advancing
this amendment so uh as uh
representative Smith said we uh were
poised actually to make some good
progress on instituting a takeback
program we actually had a uh
supplemental environmental project that
was associated with an enforcement
action we had taken uh for a facility
that was in a position to provide some
assistance and some resources for
collecting firefighting Foams from the
various municipal fire departments in
the state and as part of their uh
agreement with us we're poised to
actually take that material off their
hands and send it to an appropriate
disposal facility and we had actually
identified the disposal facility that
they would be using unfortunately before
we could launch that um there started to
be raised some question about that
specific facility but also more
generally about um the efficacy of and
and the safety of um disposing of uh
these firefighting forms through
incineration um we based on the
information we have available we
continue to believe that thermal
destruction incineration is the best uh
technology available for safe and
effective uh disposal of these materials
but that is being questioned across the
country right now EPA and the Department
of Defense which as you can imagine is a
dog in the fight here because they have
a lot of uh you know air uh uh military
bases where firefighting foam is has
been used and also had where there are
Legacy stocks of Foams that need
disposal um so they're working really
hard on uh evaluating the various uh
incineration Technologies to make sure
that they can be conducted safely but as
a result of all those uncertainties in
the industry and in the
marketplace um we we we lost our ability
and and we really weren't able to find
any disposal facilities that we could
use to to get rid of these materials so
um we've asked for this amendment uh
because we feel like we're going to need
a couple of years here additional to get
this reconciled we're hoping that with
this amendment that will provide enough
time for uh really on a national basis
uh safe effective uh Technologies and
Facilities who can actually do the work
to be identified so that we could then
put together a take back program and try
to you know collect Foams from these
various municipal fire departments and
get them safely disposed of we just
simply would be unable just practicably
to get that done we we could go and
collect it I suppose but then we'd know
have nowhere to go with it so um so what
we're looking for is to extend the
period the deadline for this and uh get
get ourselves in a position where we can
safely collect and dispose of these
materials on behalf of the the fire
departments of uh of New Hampshire
questions any questions from members of
the
committee
questions uh seeing none thank you Miss
liat
uh uh any uh any anyone else uh to speak
on this bill on the on this
amendment no other
ansers seeing none uh
I think that's uh that ends our session
concerning uh what would be call part
seven the of in other words
this uh this
amendment uh I think that's it for
uh uh I'll spill
one excuse me Senate Bill 146 is there
any uh any other business uh that anyone
on the uh committee would would wish to
point representative CR yeah Mr chairman
just a a quick question on your thoughts
next uh we've got we've got much of a
well we got much of most of May to be
able to to do this we're need we're
going to need something from uh
uh obviously from fishing
game uh and I think a lot of what
uh uh whatever they give us will uh
there'll be there'll be stuff that we
will still have to do then we'll have to
put together uh an
amendment uh to because there are things
that are going to have to happen there
are there will there will be certain
things that we will amend new you heard
of some you heard some of it already
today uh one thing I I don't know if I
think many people know and I should have
I think that was part of the discussion
uh on item two uh the the uh item two
the the text of item two is is is ALS is
being being attached to Bill 43 House
Bill four 13 in the Senate so
that uh may be that may make 413 the the
section two that we have move uh was
we'll see what what happens is premature
to even to to to be uh looking just a
look ahead but is really is premature
to predict anything uh but in
in all probability it would it would
probably happen the way that it would
become a an amend an amendment to 413
and and take it out
of uh 146 simply
because it then
protects that portion of the of the bill
for is not affected by well the other
parts of 146 so and it gets it into the
hands of the committee that uh that is
is most qualified to adjudicate it so
the any did that answer your question
okay but look probably for within within
hopefully within a couple of weeks to be
able to to do to to to do to do
something to try to get this
together I'd rather not wait till the
last
minute not that I know what the LA
exactly what the last minute is but
we'll find out
um any other uh any other business or
any other
questions repres representative Smith
yeah representative Rula or Mr chair um
have any thoughts on retained
bills uh we I'm told uh you can do your
retained bills if you get rid of your
what you have to what your workload is
okay other words so the first first
thing we have to do is get rid of this
uh get rid of 146 then we can go on
retain bills uh and but then we'll we'll
talk but I've not really thought much
about it beyond that because that's
that's the edict is we can work on
retain bills you can't vote on
them but you can work on them uh but you
got have to first get your get get your
present work done sounds good okay
anything
else
answers no hand pardon representative
post representative post for question um
so but just to clarify we're not going
to be meeting next week next
Wednesday uh no no we're not meeting uh
we'll meet
uh at the call of the chair uh we'll so
uh but yeah there we'll oh by the way I
did was mentioned um in our in our
discussion on uh uh with the fish with
fishing game a an
amendment the I guess the part five uh
I've sent that out to everyone we I only
received it of at by by the the date by
the time on the email it arrives at 857
of course I obviously was not looking at
my email at the time so uh only only saw
it at in noon time so that's so I not
only did fishing game not have it I
hadn't even read it yet so uh you all
have you all have copies of that
now other than that uh seeing nothing